Sie sind der Ort, wo die Flüge der Menschen, die Flüge des Geldes, die Flüge des Gutes sich zusammengehalten haben. Die Stadt ist immer die physische Manifestation der großen Stärken im Spiel. Das, was uns an die Stadt beiträgt, ist das Geheimnis, das Erkennen, das Wissen, dass du hier anfangen kannst, da hin und wieder zurückkommen kannst. Ihr hört, CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 200. Ausgabe. 200 Sendungen, das nicht gerade wenig. Und da dachte ich mir, da muss auch mal ein schönes Thema ran, wo Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft auch insgesamt ganz gut zusammenkommt. Und ich glaube, das Thema habe ich gefunden. Es ist Stadtplanung und dazu rede ich heute mit Thomas. Thomas Stellmach, hallo. Hallo Tim. Ja, super. Das finde ich gut. Wir kennen uns ja eigentlich schon ganz schön lange, so irgendwie, aber haben uns auch ganz gut aus den Augen verloren, so über die Jahre. Was unter anderem daran lag, dass du so viel durch die Weltgeschichte gezogen bist auf einmal. Auf einmal waren so die ganzen Ortsmeldungen, so Syrien und Afrika viel und ich glaube, das ist auch noch in diversen anderen Orten häufiger aufgeschlagen. Ja, das stimmt. Das hat ja schon alles in Berlin angefangen, aber irgendwie hat es mich dann doch in die Ferne getrieben, zuerst nach Holland, wo eigentlich die Grundsteine für meine ärztliche Ausrichtung als Stadtplaner gelegt wurden, abgesehen vom Studium zuvor. Das Studium war dann Architektur? Das Studium war Architektur, aber das Architekturstudium ist in Deutschland so angelegt, dass man sowieso was anderes wird. Da kann man am Ende Stühle designen oder eben Städte planen. Da passiert einiges. Das ist ein ganz komischer Effekt, Architekten werden irgendwie alle, meistens keine. Und die, die ja doch welche werden, sind immer ganz unglücklich. Richtig, viele Architekten haben damals ja auch angefangen, irgendwelche Clubs aufzuziehen. Das war ja auch ein Phänomen. Ja, da gehörtest du ja auch dazu. Ja, da waren wir nicht die einzigen. Das waren so einige. Das scheint auch ein Charakteristikum von dem Studium zu sein, dass man einfach anscheinend lernt, sich im Team zu organisieren und was auf die Beine zu stellen. Und deswegen kann man wohl auch alles Mögliche machen. Das ist eigentlich wirklich ein interessantes Universal-Studium, scheint es so den Eindruck zu haben. Warum eigentlich? Also ich meine, was macht das Studium an der Stelle? Ich hatte auch keine Vorstellung, was ich werden möchte und deswegen ist meine Wahl dann, glaube ich, auch auf das Architektur-Studium gefallen. Als ich eben nicht wusste, was ich studieren sollte. Ah, Architektur, es ist irgendwie Kunst und das ist irgendwie Mathematik und mit Leuten redet man auch. Das war so meine naive Vorstellung, bevor ich angefangen hatte. Es war dann am Ende doch ein bisschen anders, aber das mit der Vielfalt trifft zu. Man lernt halt generell, Generalist zu sein und das ist, glaube ich, ein großer Unterschied zu vielen anderen Berufen, die man heutzutage einschlägt. Wo es ja immer darum geht, sehr spezifisch seine Nische zu finden und ein Spezialist für irgendetwas zu werden. Und Architektur ist eben sehr breit angelegt, weil eine Hauptaufgabe das Architekten ist, eben mit verschiedenen anderen Begriffsgruppen kommunizieren zu können. Das kann ja, so ein Hausprojekt kostet ja schnell ein paar Millionen, wenn nicht hunderte Millionen. Und da muss der Architekt eben mit dem Finanzplaner und dem Ingenieur und dem Bauherrn und dem Gesetzgeber und so weiter sprechen und das alles koordinieren. Ich glaube, das ist ein Grund dafür, warum eben die Berufswahl hinterher auch so offen steht und vielfältig ist. Und als erstes traut man sich aber nicht ans Haus ran, sondern sagt, lass erst mal einen Club aufmachen. Genau, vor allem lässt einen auch kein anderer ans Haus ran. Die anderen trauen sich auch meistens nicht, dem jungen Architekten jetzt so das Projekt zu geben. Sie wollen ein Haus bauen? Haben sie überhaupt schon mal einen Club geführt? Aber ich meine, wer das gemacht hat, da kann man eine Menge lernen. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch gerade, was so die Interaktion mit anderen Menschen und das Bewältigen schwieriger Aufgaben betrifft, wahrscheinlich nicht die schlechteste Betätigung. Richtig, man lernt auch viel über das Sozialverhalten. Aber dann trotzdem, auf einmal stand dann die Stadtplanung. War das dann ein gezielter Schritt oder ja so ein Zufall, dass du da reingeraten bist? Das war beides. Also es war mit dem Club und mit der Innenarchitekturarbeit, die wir damals gemeinsam gemacht haben im Rahmen dieses Kinzo-Projektes, ganz schnell so, dass es mich nicht mehr interessiert hat. Das ist sowieso ein Charakteristikum meiner Laufbahn insgesamt. Und ich merke, dass ich alle drei Jahre, das lässt sich ziemlich genau feststellen, Lust bekomme auf etwas Neues, auf eine neue Herausforderung. Und da muss ich irgendwie alles ändern. Und dann bin ich plötzlich eben in Syrien und nicht mehr in Europa oder so etwas. Und das war da auch so. Das war eben klassischer Architektur-Innenausbau. Und dann habe ich doch mehr die komplexeren Aspekte interessiert. Und mich hat mehr interessiert, wie die Gesellschaft im Verhältnis steht zu unserer gebauten Umgebung. Das heißt automatisch, dass es größere Projekte sind, dass es eben mehr um Stadt geht als um das einzelne Gebäude oder um die einzelne Bar im Erdgeschoss. Dann habe ich mich umgeguckt und eben gesehen, dass die interessantesten Entwicklungen zur Zeit oder sagen wir zur damaligen Zeit, das war dann irgendwie gerade ein paar Jahre nach der Jahrtausendwende, so 2006 etwa, in Holland stattfinden und dort habe ich mich gezielt hinbeworben. Das war jetzt auch kein direkter Zufall, da ich im Studium schon mit holländischen Professoren in Verbindung stand. Und dann habe ich dort eben in einem sehr interessanten Stadtplanungsbüro gearbeitet und sozusagen direkt vom Design eines einzelnen Tisches zum Design einer Stadterweiterung für Moskau für 350.000 Menschen angekommen bin. Und das war auch erstmal ein gewisser Schock. Das sind dann so Effekte, dass man vor dem Plan sitzt und weiß, wenn ich jetzt hier diese Linie zeichne und das ist die Autobahn, dann muss dieses Dorf hier weg. Und dann sitzt man erst mal da und traut sich eine Weile nicht. Und da ging es dann eben darum, sich an diesen größeren Maßstab zu gewöhnen. Dazu fällt mir auch ein Zitat ein, das während des Job-Interviews damals gefallen ist, von Reens Dijkstra, der mich dann eben dort eingestellt hat. Er hat gemeint, ja, okay, du hast den Job. Und als ich dann doch leichte Bedenken angemeldet habe, ich freue mich zwar sehr, aber vielleicht ist es doch etwas schnell, jetzt gleich an so ein Riesenprojekt zu gehen, und er sagt ja, ja, ja, Thomas, was ich hier brauche, sind Leute mit so einem Architekturhintergrund. Und wenn sie gesunden Menschenverstand haben, dann kann ich denen das mit der Stadtplanung in zwei, drei Stunden beibringen. Ich weiß nicht, wie ernst du das gemeint hast, aber irgendwie so ist es dann doch gelaufen. Ich will jetzt den Beruf natürlich nicht kleinreden, dass wir hier lauter empörte Anrufe gleich bekommen. Ich denke nicht. Aber es ist eben schon so, dass es, wie gesagt, ein so weites Feld ist, dass man mit so einer allgemeinen Neugier auf die Gesellschaft, auf Politik, auf technologische Aspekte, auf unsere Umgebung eigentlich einen ganz guten Einstieg hat, um um dieses Gebiet anzugehen. Und dann kann man sich natürlich auch spezialisieren. Ich meine, jetzt kommt natürlich alles zusammen bei der Stadt, was du vorhin ja auch schon aufgezählt hast, wie man bei einem Haus so technische Planung und soziale Gegebenheiten berücksichtigen muss. Das ist ja dann letztlich bei der ganzen Stadt genauso, nur halt in einer ganz anderen Dimension. Ja, richtig. Also es gab natürlich auch vielfältige Versuche, durch die Geschichte hinweg immer wieder Stadt zu verstehen. Das ist auch immer ein ganz guter Spiegel der Gesellschaft. Bestimmte Idealbilder von Gesellschaft wurden dann auch immer wieder auf die Stadt projiziert. Und dann kann man natürlich sehen, dass zu Zeiten von absolutistischer Herrschaft in Frankreich Louis XIV ein anderes Bild von Stadt hatte, als jetzt heutzutage, wo es eher so Ideen gibt von Komplexitätstheorie, Chaos-Theorie und so weiter, dass alles wie ein verteiltes Netzwerk funktioniert, wo sich verschiedenste Faktoren gegenseitig beeinflussen. Das heißt, die Stadt ist vielleicht das komplexeste System, das wir als Menschen entwickelt haben. Ob jetzt so gezielt oder ob das eher aus sich selbst heraus erstanden ist, können wir gerne offen lassen. Und deswegen gibt es eben auch vielfältigste Ansätze, die Stadt zu verstehen. Das ist ja nicht nur auf Stadtplaner beschränkt. Es gibt ja genauso Stadtsoziologen. Es gibt ja genauso vielfältige technische Initiativen. Auch gerade in den letzten Jahren versuchen globale Firmen diesen Begriff zu besetzen. Smart City zum Beispiel. IBM versucht da mit einer Initiative, das zu besetzen. Genauso wie Samsung und so weiter. Diese ganzen Konzerne versuchen eben da auch wiederum, eher von der technologischen Seite her, die Stadt zu verstehen als System. Zu verstehen oder die Begriffe zu besetzen? Ja, natürlich erstmal als Firmen die Begriffe zu besetzen, um Geld damit zu verdienen. Aber da geht es eben auch darum, die Stadt eben als System zu sehen und zu versuchen zu verstehen, wie man diese beeinflussen kann, was es da für Stellschrauben gibt. Natürlich geht es da ganz schnell eben auch eher um infrastrukturelle Dinge, also zum Beispiel Verkehrssteuerung oder so Liefersysteme, das zum Beispiel in so sehr dichten Städten wie in Tokio ganz interessant. Wie funktioniert das, dass dann 18 Millionen Menschen jeden Morgen ihr Frühstück irgendwie bekommen? Das ist ja eine gewisse Leistung. Also du bist dann, um vielleicht mal deinen persönlichen Teil abzuschließen, dann in Holland eigentlich erstmal so ein bisschen in eine Ausbildung hineingeraten, aber dann eben schon jetzt nicht als Lehrbetrieb, sondern eben mit hier Stadtteil Machma. Genau, das war so Learning by Doing ganz klar. Nach drei Stunden hat es es drauf. Nach drei Stunden habe ich auch gedacht, danke, es reicht. Jetzt kann ich weitermachen alleine. Erst in drei Stunden sind dann drei Jahre geworden, die ich insgesamt in Holland verbracht habe. Zwischendurch war ich insgesamt ein Jahr in Syrien und habe dort in Aleppo gelehrt, Stadtplanung und auch ein bisschen Architektur. Das war so ein Intermezzo. Ich bin danach wieder nach Holland zurückgegangen. Syrien ist natürlich jetzt noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema, gerade wie sich das im Moment entwickelt, aber das sprengt jetzt hier vielleicht den Rahmen. Und nach dieser Zeit bei Marx waren, so hieß das Büro in Holland, habe ich angefangen, auch in Rotterdam zu lehren, an so einem Postgraduate-Institut. Also das waren alles schon fertige Architekten und Stadtplaner, die dort eben noch mal zwei Jahre etwas dazulernen wollten. Und da habe ich auch gemeinsam mit Rienz Deichstra, meinem damaligen Chef, eben Seminare gelehrt. Und dann ging es wieder zurück nach Berlin, mit der Idee, meine eigene Firma für Stadtplanung zu gründen, gemeinsam mit meinem Partner Ali Saad. Wir haben jetzt hier auch ein Büro in Kreuzberg. Und unser großes, unser Startprojekt, das es überhaupt ermöglicht hat, war ein Auftrag, die Entwicklungsvision eben auch für Aleppo in Syrien zu entwickeln. Im Auftrag der GIZ, der Gesellschaft für internationale Zusammenarbeit, hier unsere Deutsche Entwicklungsgesellschaft. Und das war halt gleich so ein richtig dicker Einstieg, um es mal sozusagen, wo man sagen kann, okay, hier können wir anfangen. Und daraus hat sich eigentlich dann alles weiter ergeben. Weitere natürlich, weitere Einladungen für Konferenzen, dadurch Folgeaufträge und so weiter. Und letztlich hat das dazu geführt, dass ich im Moment drei Standbeine habe. Zum einen ist es eben das Büroüberbau, das wir hier in Berlin haben. Zum zweiten ist es Lehre an Hochschulen und Universitäten, was ich im Moment weniger mache, weil es eben noch die dritte Schiene gibt. Und das sind so Consulting- oder eben Beraterverträge auf Deutsch für die GIZ oder im Moment für die Vereinten Nation United Nations Habitat. Das ist der Zweig der Vereinten Nation, der eben für Stadtentwicklung und generell Hausbau, Shelter, sagt man auf Englisch, da verantwortlich ist. Und für die reise ich dann auch weiterhin viel durch die Gegend. Habitat, UN-Habitat. Ich hab das nie gehört. Ehrlich? Hab ich das schon mal gehört? Die haben ja offensichtlich so viele Unterprogramme und einzelne Aktivitäten. Okay, achso, und deswegen bist du auch immer in Kenia, weil die Nairobi ihren Sitz haben sozusagen. Richtig, genau. Und die GIZ, ich musste kurz stutzen, als du es vorhin gesagt hast, weil ich immer GTZ im Kopf habe, aber die sind ja gerade erst verschmolzen worden, da zusammen mit dem deutschen Entwicklungsdienst. Genau. Weil GTZ, das war ja das, was man ja eigentlich jetzt schon seit Jahrzehnten kennt. Wenn man so ein bisschen travelt, dann und so ein bisschen in die entlegenen Regionen dieses Planeten kommt, ich kenne das konkret aus Afrika, da gibt es dann halt irgendwo dann immer eine GTZ-Niederlassung, die dann so Straßen bauen und dann eben wahrscheinlich auch Stadtplanung machen. Genau. Ich habe da damals auch für die GTZ gearbeitet, aber inzwischen habe ich mir angewöhnt, GIZ zu sagen. Es war damals die GTZ und dazwischen ist es die GIZ. Verdammt nah an der GIZ, aber sie kommt jetzt hier, die heißt jetzt auch nicht mehr so. Alles ändert sich. Ich würde gerne mal so ein bisschen zurückblicken, weil Stadtplanung ist ja jetzt nichts, was es jetzt erst seit fünf Jahren gibt. Im Prinzip spielt das ja eine Rolle, seitdem es Städte gibt und die gibt es schon lange. Und so der Blick in die Vergangenheit ist ja eigentlich immer sehr erleuchtend, weil früher gab es auch Probleme, wenn auch ganz andere. Und das, was man heutzutage so als Organismus Stadt kennenlernt, ist ja im Prinzip schon das Produkt von Jahrtausend langer Entwicklung. Ich muss auch sagen, das ist so ein Ding, das macht man sich irgendwie gar nicht so richtig klar. Vor allem, wenn man in der Stadt groß wird und das alles erstmal so als gegeben hinnimmt, was eigentlich so alles dazugehört, um so einen Mechanismus am Laufen zu halten. Also angefangen von all dem, was so im Untergrund vor sich hin schlummert. Man ist immer wieder überrascht, nicht wahr? Also klar, das Offensichtliche, irgendwo läuft ja das Wasser hin. Irgendwo kommt es ja auch irgendwie her. Aber wie das dann konkret aussieht, das weiß man nicht. Dann geht es eben weiter über Gas, Tanks und was da nicht alles im Boden noch so schlummert. Bis hin halt dabei auch zu den ganzen Funktionsgebäuden und Funktionssystemen, die so eine Stadt ausmacht. Stadt, aber jetzt erstmal als Unterschied zum Dorf. Ab wann kann man denn eigentlich sagen, gibt es Städte? Also ich meine, ist jetzt alles, wo sich mehr als fünf Leute um den Bauernhof scharen, schon automatisch eine Stadt? Was ist denn die Definition an der Stelle des Begriffs? Ja, da können wir eine Weile zurückgehen. Also eigentlich kann man sagen, dass es die ersten Ansiedlungen oder Dörfer gab, als die Menschen gelernt haben, was Ackerbau ist. Und das war, wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch liege, so vor etwa 10.000 Jahren. Nach der letzten großen Eiszeit sind die Leute sesshafter geworden und haben eben angefangen permanent an einem Ort zu bleiben und nicht mehr als Jäger und Sammler durch die Gegend zu ziehen, als eben den normalischen Lebensstil zu verfolgen. Und das sind dann so auch die Bilder, die man kennt, von so Hütten, einzelnen Hütten und vielleicht sogar eine Palisade außen rum, damit die Nachbarn, die neidisch sind, dann nicht nachts da kommen und die Vierträgerkammer oder die Frauen oder was auch immer mitnehmen. Dann gab es eine ziemlich interessante Entwicklung. Und das war vor etwa 5000 Jahren im vorderen Orient. Und zwar war das einfach eine extrem fruchtbare Gegend durch immer wieder Überschwemmung von wahrscheinlich Euphrates und Tigris, die Zweiflüsse kennt man ja auch, biblisch und natürlich auch am Nil, dass es da einfach einen Überschuss an Nahrung gab. Das heißt, es wurde plötzlich möglich, dass Leute was anderes tun als permanent zu ackern. Das ist ja auch das Wort, um das es hier geht, ackern. Das heißt, das hat eigentlich erst Arbeitsteil und Arbeitsteilung ermöglicht. Nicht jeder musste auf dem Feld stehen, sondern es gab eben eine Überproduktion. Und das hat es ermöglicht zu sagen, okay, jetzt halten wir mal ein paar Leute zurück und bilden die als Krieger aus. Oder jetzt haben wir mal jemand, der das hier alles ein bisschen organisiert oder der sich darum kümmert, wie das Wasser verteilt wird auf die einzelnen Äcker. Und ich denke, das war der Ursprung der Arbeitsteilung und auch gleichzeitig der Ursprung der Stadt. Weil das sozusagen die ersten Ansätze waren, dass eben die Gesellschaft sich als Organismus mit verschiedenen Untergruppen organisiert. Und sobald es so eine Organisationsform gibt, die eben sesshaft ist, hast du auch ganz schnell Stadt. Und du hast auch ganz schnell Handel zum Beispiel, was auch ein Merkmal ist der Stadt. Das sind ja auch oft Marktplätze gewesen oder bis heute die wichtigsten Städte sind entstanden an Kreuzungspunkten von Handelsrouten. Und Handel ist eben auch erst möglich geworden dadurch, dass es gewisse Überschüsse gab, die dann eben verkauft werden konnten. Und dann kommt man da ganz schnell dazu. Und das ist auch alles in einer ähnlichen Zeit geschehen. Das geht dann wirklich parallel einher mit der Entwicklung der Schrift. Das war auch in Mesopotamien vor zur gleichen Zeit, vor etwa 5000 Jahren gab es so die ersten Systeme, wie man etwas niederschreiben konnte. Da ging es auch um Zählen und um Handeln und um eben Organisieren letztlich. Und ich denke, auch vorher gab es schon, wenn man so möchte, permanente Bauwerke, die jetzt mehr waren als eine Hütte. Aber das waren eher oft religiös motivierte Ausnahmen. Das kann man heute schwer nachvollziehen, warum es dann plötzlich Stonehenge oder sowas gibt. Das ist jetzt natürlich keine Stadt, aber immerhin so eine permanente Struktur, die auch ganz schön viele Organisationen und in gewisser Weise mehr Einsatz erfordert. Aber das waren eher Ausnahmen. Und mit der Stadt ist das sozusagen, hat sich das verfestigt, dass es auch so über die Generation hinweg so ein Investieren in die Gesellschaft gab. Also Mesopotamien, muss man dazu sagen, das ist halt diese Euphrat-Region, die sich halt von Aleppo, wo du warst, im Prinzip so in der Gegend bis hin zum Irak erstreckt. Genau. Also babilolisches Gebiet, etc. Ja genau, der Babylon ist ja auch heute im südlichen Irak. Das ist so die Gegend. Und das waren dann auch ganz schnell die Machtzentren. Das waren dann alles so einzelne Stadtstaaten, die sich eben um ihre jeweiligen Hauptstädte gruppiert haben und die dann auch ganz schnell durch den Überfluss an Nahrung einen gewissen Bevölkerungsüberschuss sich leisten konnten. Und dadurch sind die dann auch ganz schnell machtpolitisch weitergekommen und eben auch kulturell. Man kann sagen, dass es parallel zu dieser Entwicklung im Mittleren Osten noch eine Entwicklung, über die ich jetzt weniger weiß, in Ostasien gab. Also im heutigen China ist zu der gleichen Zeit etwas Ähnliches passiert. Also wenn man sich heute jetzt anguckt, das gibt es etwa zehn Städte, die sich darum streiten, dass sie die ältesten bis heute bewohnten Städte sind. Und da sind dann die fünf, sechs im Mittleren Osten, unter anderem auch Damaskus und Aleppo. Und dann gibt es noch vier, fünf in China, die das Gleiche von sich bauten, die eben auch sagen, wir haben 5000 Jahre Geschichte hier. Verstehe, aber alles mehr oder weniger zeitgleich. Genau, ja. Gut, was wahrscheinlich auch schlicht darin begründet, dass natürlich auch die Voraussetzungen dafür, klimatischen Gesamtbedingungen der Erde zu suchen sind, weil ja nicht immer gleich warm und gleich feucht. Genau. Wahrscheinlich hat das eben nach dieser Eiszeit ein paar tausend Jahre gedauert, bis sich diese Ackerbohrmethoden und so weiter so weit verfestigt haben, dass eben es dazu kommen konnte, dass so eine kritische Masse entstanden ist an Produktionstechnologie und an Kultur und vielleicht auch an Zucht von Tieren. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Was jetzt stadtplanerisch wieder interessant ist, dass sich die Städte in China formal stark unterschieden haben von den Städten im Mittleren Osten. Das ist ein Thema, das eigentlich bis heute relevant ist. Die mesopotamischen Städte, die waren chaotisch und selbstorganisiert. Das waren sozusagen Ansammlungen von Häusern, sehr dicht, die sich verfestigt haben, die man so ineinander geschachtelt. Das kennt man auch fast heute noch von der arabischen Stadt oder wenn man irgendwo in Südspanien ist. Das ist so diese Urstruktur. Natürlich war die muslimische Stadt viel später, aber eine, sagen wir, ohne höheres Organisationsprinzip ungeordnete Struktur von Ansiedlung, ein Haus neben den anderen, aus sich selbst entstanden. Wogegen die chinesischen Städte aus der Zeit viel mehr einem universellen Prinzip folgen. Also da gab es wohl eine Vorstellung von einer göttlichen Ordnung, der gefolgt werden muss. Die Städte waren immer Nord-Süd ausgerichtet an den Himmelsrichtungen, waren immer rechteckig oder quadratisch und da waren in einzelnen Ringen auch ganz klar ablesbar, dass es von so einer gewissen Funktionstrennung gab. Also es gab so einen inneren Ring, die eigentliche Stadt mit einer Mauer außenrum und dann gab es darum einen äußeren Ring, der nur dazu diente, dass die Bauern aus dem Umland, wenn die Stadt angegriffen wurde, dahin fliehen können und sich eben schützen können, bis dieser Angriff vorbei ist. Ja, und diese verschiedenen formalen Ausprägungen spielen auch in der Geschichte immer wieder weiterhin eine Rolle und definieren bis heute den Charakter von der Stadt. Das sieht man an den europäischen mittelalterlichen Städten. Das ist jetzt ein ganz schöner Sprung, die natürlich eine andere Straßenstruktur haben als so geplante Städte wie New York oder Barcelona, die Stadterweiterung. Aber auch mit inneren Ringen und äußeren Ringen und ähnlichen Funktionsbedurchschnitt an der Stelle. Interessant, also die Stadt hat sich sozusagen aus den thematischen und menschlichen Weiterentwicklungsbedingungen herausgebildet und dokumentiert im Prinzip den Wandel des Menschen von dem zu permanenter Selbstversorgung verpflichteten Individuum hin zu einer Kooperation von Spezialisierungen und Tätigkeiten, die das Einzelne erlaubte, sich auch anderen Dingen zuzuwenden, die dann im Umkehrschluss wiederum allen zugute kamen, weil man auf einmal in der Lage war, organisatorisch Dinge zu stemmen, wo eben, wenn jeder für sich alleine arbeitet, das überhaupt nicht machbar gewesen wäre. Wenn man so möchte, um ganz kurz ins Heute zu springen, kann man das immer noch beobachten, dass auch heute, wo wir vernetzt sind, eigentlich die kulturellen und auch technischen, oft technischen Innovationen trotzdem immer wieder dort stattfinden, wo sich einfach sehr viele Menschen begegnen, wo es eben nicht nur einen Überfluss an, jetzt sei es ein Überfluss an Nahrungsmitteln oder technische Möglichkeiten gibt, sondern sozusagen eben auch einen Überfluss an Lebensstilen, an Kultur. Deswegen zieht es immer wieder die Kreativen in die großen Städte und deswegen kommen oft auch neue Impulse aus den Städten. Also das lässt sich eigentlich über diese ganzen Jahrtausende immer wieder... Was wäre da ein Beispiel für dich? Ein Beispiel, da könnte man sich die Musikszene zum Beispiel ansehen. Also wenn jetzt mal wirklich ein neuer Trend entsteht, sei es Techno in Detroit, dann passiert sowas dann doch oft in einer Stadt. Aber in welchen Städten? Das ist mir im Moment... Okay, können wir drüber reden. Im Moment war mir das ganz egal. Im Moment ist die Hypothese noch, es gibt einen Haufen von Menschen, die alle irgendwie unterschiedlich drauf sind. Sagen wir ja etwas seriöser, formuliert unterschiedliche Ideen und Hintergründe haben, die dann sozusagen eine gewisse kreative Masse erreichen und dass daraus etwas Neues entsteht, dass sozusagen so ein Remix gibt. Ja, dafür braucht es überhaupt erst mal diese urbane Verdichtung. Dafür braucht es die lebendige Stadt, die urbane Verdichtung. Und dann, wenn du jetzt fragst, was sind die genauen Konditionen? Bei Städte gibt es ja viele, aber nicht alle liefern jetzt permanent kulturelle Neuerungen ab. Richtig, und das ist eine ganz heiße Diskussion. Also da gibt es auch einen Haufen Veröffentlichungen, zum Beispiel eben, das war ein richtiger Hit auch in der Populärliteratur, nicht nur für Fachleute, Creative City von Richard Floyder. Der hat eben diesen Begriff auch besetzt, die kreative Stadt, der dann eben genau diese Hypothese aufstellt, dass es eine Stadt mit gewissen Faktoren braucht, um eben global wettbewerbsfähig zu sein. Und anscheinend ist das eben auch eine Stadt, die durchmischt ist, wo es ein gewisses öffentliches Leben gibt, wo Leben und Arbeiten integriert ist. Jetzt sagen wir mal im Gegensatz zu einer eher modernistisch ausgeprägten Stadt, was es genau bedeutet, kommen wir ja auch noch später drauf, wo es eben ein reines Wohnviertel gibt und ein reines Viertel, in dem man arbeitet und dazwischen bewegt man sich mit dem Auto und ansonsten schläft man und geht ab und zu in die Shopping-Mall und kauft ein. Unter solchen Bedingungen ist es natürlich schwieriger, sagen wir mal so eine Pertiziatives Verlust zu entfalten. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch, um jetzt hier nach Berlin zu springen, wo wir ja gerade sind, dass eben so eine Stadt wie Berlin ausmacht oder in einem größeren Kontext die europäische Stadt, dass da eben aus wiederum gewissen geschichtlichen Gründen bis heute Bedingungen entstanden sind, die sowas eben einfacher machen. Also, dass es nicht so viele funktionale Trennungen gibt? Genau. Man kann eigentlich in Berlin viel Fußläufig erreichen und das hat eben ganz viel mit dieser Typologie der Stadt zu tun und mit der Typologie der Stadt, die hier im 19. Jahrhundert erbaut wurde. Man sieht ja, dass diese ganzen Gründerzeitgebäude, das ist jetzt ein Architekturthema, aber dennoch, dass diese Gebäude als alles Mögliche nutzbar sind. Als Podcast-Studio oder als Wohnung oder als Architekturbüro oder als Werkstatt. Und das ist nicht unbedingt in jeder Stadt so. Das stimmt. Lass uns vielleicht den geschichtlichen Ausblick noch nicht so ganz beiseite legen, weil wir sind ja irgendwie noch so ein bisschen am Anfang gefühlt. Also die Städte haben sich nun entwickelt. China, Mesopotamien, aber die Menschheit hat sich ja dann gerade in den letzten 5000 Jahren dann auch dynamisch und dramatisch ausgeweitet und über den ganzen Planeten verstreut. Wann ist denn so die nächste Änderung in dem Modell stattfestzustellen? Also die nächste Änderung kann man beobachten seit vor gut 2000 Jahren. Nein, Entschuldigung, vor gut 3000 Jahren, so 1200 vor Christus, als eben das antike Griechenland sozusagen langsam zu seiner Blüte gekommen ist. Auch da sieht man eine ähnliche Entwicklung in China. Wahrscheinlich liegt diesem Wandel zu größeren Städten auch wieder einer technologischen Ursache zugrunde. Das ist übrigens immer wieder zu beobachten. Das wird auch später interessant mit dem Aufkommen des Automobilverkehrs und so weiter. Das ist oft ganz kleine, technische Neuerungen sind, die einen riesigen Einfluss auf die Gesellschaft und damit auf die Stadt haben. Und in dem Fall reden wir davon, dass die Bronze, deswegen auch Bronzezeit, mit der zuvor Werkzeuge und Waffen hergestellt wurden, sehr knapp war und plötzlich haben die Leute gelernt, mit Eisen umzugehen und von dem gab es einfach viel mehr. Und plötzlich konnten die Technologiensprung nach vorne machen und plötzlich konnten Heere ausgestattet werden und plötzlich konnten Flugscharen auch geschmiedet werden, die die ersten Maschinen hergestellt werden. Und das führte daneben auch zu einem Entwicklungssprung wieder in dem Bild der Stadt. Und hier geht vielleicht auch für den Europäer erst die Idee der Stadt los. Da wird ja auch ganz oft in unserer kontemporären politischen Diskussion so das Bild der Polis heraufbeschworen, so der Einheit der Gesellschaft, die eben in dem Griechenland, in dem klassischen Griechenland gleich war mit der Einheit der Stadt. Das ist ganz interessant. Also es gab die Gesellschaft und die Gesellschaft war zugleich die Stadt und die Stadt wurde als Einheit gesehen. Also auch ganz anders als in dem chinesischen Bild, von dem wir vorher gesprochen haben, mit den verschiedenen Ringen. Da gab es eine innere Stadt und eine äußere Stadt, eine gewisse Hierarchie und das war im klassischen Griechenland nicht so. Aristoteles bezeichnet da einen gewissen Hippodamus von Milet als nicht nur, sagen wir, Gründer oder Ideengeber der ersten Idee der Stadt, sondern gleichzeitig als Gesellschaftstheoretiker. Milet ist eben auch die Stadt, die hier geplant wird. Und das ist interessanterweise eben auch die erste Stadt, die wir, oder eine der ersten Städte, um genau zu sein, die wir im europäischen Raum kennen, die einen Straßenraste hatte. Also vorher die europäischen Städte waren eben, und auch die, die natürlich die Städte im mittleren Osten, wo sich die Verstattung langsam Richtung Europa im östlichen Mittelmeer ausgedehnt hat, die waren eben alle umgeplant. Und plötzlich sehen wir in Griechenland die ersten geplanten Städte, weil es eben auch wieder ein ideales Bild von einer Gesellschaft gab. Und es gab auch eine, sagen wir, ausreichende Machtkonzentration, die eben so ein Durchsetzen von Planung überhaupt möglich gemacht hat. Also es gab ein Straßenraster und die Häuser waren ganz klar an diesem Straßenraster angeordnet. Und es gab eine sehr klare Identifizierung von drei verschiedenen Funktionsbereichen der Stadt. Und das war das Private, die Wohnhäuser. Und dann das Heilige, das waren die Tempel. Und zum Dritten eben das Öffentliche, wo Verkehr und Handel und so weiter stattgefunden haben. Aber eben auch die politische Diskussion, die Agora oder später in Rom das Forum. Und das kann man auch heute noch sehen, wenn die Archäologen das ausgraben, eben das Raster und dann klar identifizierbare Bereiche für religiöser oder Handelsfunktionen. Und das war neu. Und interessant ist vielleicht auch, dass zu der gleichen Zeit oder etwas später Plato in einem seiner Dialoge ein Bild entwickelt hat von der idealen Gesellschaft, die sich sehr stark auf dieses Stadtmodell bezieht. Er sagt nämlich, dass die ideale Gesellschaft aus maximal 10.000 Einwohnern besteht, aus Bürgern, pardon, aus 10.000 Bürgern besteht. Dazu muss man wissen, dass wenn Plato sagt 10.000 Bürger, dann sind das etwa 50.000 Menschen. Weil die Frauen und die Kinder und die Sklaven sind natürlich keine Bürger. Und dass wenn die Bevölkerung größer wird als diese 10.000 oder eben 50.000, dass dann eine neue Stadt gegründet werden muss. Weil das sei die Maximalanzahl, wo politische Öffentlichkeit möglich ist. Ohne Mikrofone und Internet. 10.000, das kriegt man auch hin, dass die alle auf den Platz gehen und entscheiden, was los ist. Und den Redner verstehen oder sich zumindest weiter erzählen, was gerade die Diskussion ist. Und darüber hinaus bricht das dann zusammen. Und wiederum sieht man, dass eine bestimmte Idee an der Stadt und des Raums und eine bestimmte Idee an der Gesellschaft sich gegenseitig widerspiegeln. War das eigentlich eine These oder eine Erfahrung? Waren die Städte damals so groß? Das hat gepasst. Das ist natürlich eine Henne- und Eifrage. Vielleicht ist die These entstanden, weil das genau die Lebensumgebung war der Menschen, die das gesehen haben. Aber sicherlich gab es da... Ich frage mich, ob das jetzt auch so stattgefunden hat, dass sie jetzt wirklich gesagt haben, okay, wir sind jetzt zu viele, wir müssen uns jetzt mal aufspalten. Geht man woanders hin? Wissen wir nicht, aber was wir wissen, ist doch, dass Athen zu seiner Blütezeit etwa 40.000 Einwohner hatte. Vielleicht 800 vor Christus. Auf die genaue Zeit will ich mich jetzt nicht fest nageln. Okay, das wäre ja so etwa die Zahl. Puh, krass, 40.000 Einwohner. Nüscht ist das. Würde man heute noch nicht mal ernst nehmen, so ein Fleck. Ja, das ist nüscht. Aber auf der anderen Seite, nicht viel später, zu römischen Zeiten, gab es dann ganz schnell Städte mit 300.000 Einwohnern, was ja schon selbst für heutige Verhältnisse, zumindest im europäischen Raum, als Stadt bezeichnet wird. Die Deutschen nennen zum Beispiel alles Stadt, was mehr als 100.000 Einwohner hat. Im asiatischen Raum würde man das oft nicht mal als Dorf bezeichnen, heutzutage. Da gibt es eben auch ganz unterschiedliche Auffassungen. Das heißt, die Römer waren dann im Prinzip auch der nächste Schritt? Die Römer waren der nächste Schritt. Was bei Rom interessant ist, ist vielleicht nicht so sehr ein Weiterentwickeln der Idee der Stadt, weil eigentlich die Griechen schon die ganzen Grundlagen geschaffen haben. Die römische Stadt war sehr ähnlich organisiert. Was interessant ist, ist, dass es bei Rom wieder viel mehr um den nächsten Maßstab ging. Da ging es um ein Weltreich. Das heißt, es hat bestimmte infrastrukturelle Anforderungen plötzlich gehabt. Highways, vernünftige Straßen, wo die Heere schnell bewegt werden konnten. Aber die hatten auch schon sehr kontemporär gelingende Probleme, was Verkehr betrifft, Bewässerung, Abfallbeseitigung usw. Also Rom selbst als Großstadt in der damaligen Zeit hatte mit Problemen zu kämpfen, die uns sehr bekannt vorkommen. Zum Beispiel gab es in Rom ein Gesetz, das Lieferverkehr tagsüber nicht stattfinden darf. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Es durften keine Lkws tagsüber fahren. Lkws waren dann eben die Pferdekarren, weil einfach für die Fußgänger nicht genug Platz auf der Straße war. Die mussten nachts fahren und die Geschäfte beliefern. Genauso sehen wir bis heute die Aquedukter. Das waren die Wasserinfrastrukturprojekte. Bis heute erhalten sind die römischen Straßen, weil die technisch hervorragend gelöst wurden. Die Römer haben dann eben auch den Beton erfunden. Das Wissen ist dann wieder verloren gegangen übers Mittelalter und den haben wir dann in der Neuzeit noch mal erfunden. Aber Aquedukte sind zum Teil betoniert, ganz klar. Krass. Was haben die Römer jemals für uns getan? Nichts. Gleichberechtigung. Ja, das ist interessant. Du sagtest ja vorhin schon, die Technik bringt dann eben auch die nächste Revolution. Das würde ich jetzt hier glatt mal unterstellen. Ich meine, es mag auch dieser weltreich Anspruch sein, aber dieser Anspruch hätte sich sicherlich nicht entwickelt. Hätte man nicht auch die Möglichkeit gesehen, das überhaupt erst mal zu tun? Und da scheint mir diese technische Innovation doch eine sehr große Rolle zu spielen. Ich meine, das ist schon erstaunlich. Ich überblick das gar nicht so, aber mir fallen jetzt auch noch ein paar andere Sachen ein, was ja damals auch schon so da entwickelt wurde, wie zum Beispiel Fußbodenheizung. Ja, also, allein der Gedanke. Das ist irre. Und daher meine Frage, warum Rom? Was haben die denn da, was hat die denn so kreativ gemacht? War das jetzt einfach nur so eine Kulmination von Entdeckungen mit, wir wissen jetzt hier mit dem Eisen und mit den Schiffen kriegen wir es irgendwie auch hin, dass sich dadurch einfach schon mal so eine Kulmination technischen Fortschritts einfach aus sich heraus durch die Kombination dieser Techniken ergeben hat? Oder war es vielleicht auch in ihrem konkreten urbanen Raum, den sie sich dort geschaffen haben, dass da eben diese von dir so beschworene Kreativität eine große Rolle gespielt hat? Also wie funktional ausgelegt war Rom? Ich kenne die Hintergründe nicht genau. Ich glaube, der Vorteil der Römer war in den Anfangszeiten, dass sie ein Gesellschaftssystem hatten, das sehr effizient organisiert war. Also dass es weniger interne Streitereien gab, dass es eine klare Arbeitsteilung wiederum gab, dass die Klassen sehr gut, was heißt gut, effizient organisiert waren. Und später wiederum, zu den Beginn des Weltreichs, hat sich die Überlegenheit der Römer oft dadurch manifestiert, dass die einfach sehr viel besser organisiert waren. Das ist eigentlich ein ähnliches Thema als die anderen Heere. Da geht es ganz klar um das Militär jetzt und um Expansionen. Es war eben klar, den Römern war klar, dass das Kriege oft durch die Nachversorgung der Soldaten gewonnen werden. Deswegen dieses unglaubliche Straßensystem. Da gab es einfach Schub, da gab es einfach Infrastruktur. Und dann diese ungeheure Ausbildung und Disziplin, die es gab. Da gibt es ja diese Phalanx, diese Bilder, die man auch aus Asterix und Oeobelix kennt, wobei da oft die Karten anders gemischt sind in dem Comic. Also diese Kopierung der Truppen. Genau, sehr kopiert, mit den Schildern eng gedrängt. Und dann eben Krieg führen, anstatt einfach drauf loszustürmen. Und das sind wohl die Faktoren unter vielem anderen, nehme ich an, warum Rom sich da so durchgesetzt hat. Noch mal zu den Straßen. Da fällt mir eine interessante Anekdote ein, wobei man den Weizgehalt anzweifeln kann. Und zwar, dass Straßen eben sehr permanent sind. Also das ist erstmal etwas, das wir bis heute sehen, dass oft die Hauptplätze einer Stadt an einem Kreuzpunkt von zwei Straßen liegen, die es von seit Hunderten oder Jahrtausenden gibt. Also man sieht heute immer noch in Frankfurt, wo die mit den alterlichen Handelswege waren. Das kann man heute noch im Stadtplan ablesen. Und gleichzeitig, dass es so eine technologische Kontinuität gibt. Es gibt nämlich die Story, dass sich die Spurbreite der heutigen Straßenbahnen darauf bezieht auf die Spurbreite der römischen Streitwägen. Und zwar lag das ganz einfach daran, dass die Römer auf ihren Ausfallstraßen mit ihrer Spurbreite gefahren sind. Und dadurch haben sich natürlich in den Straßen die Zirrilen eingearbeitet. Das heißt, bis ins Mittelalter haben die Holzkarren der Bauern die gleiche Spurbreite gehabt, weil andererseits werden einfach die Räder zerbrochen. Die sind halt an den gleichen Drillen gefahren. Und später, als es dann zur Industrialisierung kam, haben sie die Straßenbahn einfach mit der gleichen etablierten Spurbreite gebaut. Es hatte sich die Werkbänke, die ganzen Werkzeuge, das war einfach der Standard. Kannte man, wusste man, wie es geht. Und deswegen haben wir bis heute die Spurbreite der doppelten Pferdearsches des römischen Streitwagens. Aber das ist ganz interessant, dass es da eine Permanenz gibt von Infrastruktur, die weit über einzelne Gebäude hinausgeht. Also wir haben viel ältere Straßen und viel ältere Stadtgrundrisse, als wir einzelne Gebäude haben. Das war Rom. Das war Rom. Wie geht's weiter? Dunkle Zeiten brechen an. Ja, danach gab es ja irgendwie so ein bisschen, danach war es ja so ein bisschen weniger kreativ. Ja, da gab es das. Erscheint zumindest so, weiß nicht, war es auch so, was das Stadtplanerische betrifft? Na ja, das Römische Reich ist zusammengebrochen in sich, aus Dekadenz und vielleicht Übergröße. Und dann fingen die finsteren Zeiten an, die auch deswegen finster genannt werden, weil wir kaum Dokumentation haben und oft gar nicht so im Detail wissen, was da passiert ist. Für die Leute im frühen Mittelalter müssen die römischen Überreste der Städte, gerade in Zentrale und Nordeuropa, absurde Strukturen gewesen sein, die fast wie von Aliens irgendwie erbaut gewesen sind. Dass wir jetzt eine Raumstation abgestürzt haben. Weil die technischen Möglichkeiten gar nicht mehr da waren. Da gibt es sehr interessante Beispiele. Zum Beispiel ist in Frankreich und in Norditalien gibt es Städte, wo zum Beispiel der Stadtkern in dem alten Amphitheater der Römer erbaut wurde. Das heißt, die ganze Stadt war in dem Amphitheater und war deswegen einfach rund. Weil sie teilweise die Mauern benutzt haben. Es ist leicht, dann eine Hütte zu bauen, die sich an so eine alte Mauer anlehnt, als noch mal neu. Es gibt eine andere Stadtstruktur. Ich glaube, in Serbien müsste ich gleich mal nachgucken. Wo der ganze Stadtkern, vielleicht war das sogar Split, wo der ganze Stadtkern sich in einem alten römischen Palast befindet. Und sozusagen die Außenmauern sind noch da von dem Palast, aber drinnen ist eine Stadt mit Straßen. Weil der Palast einfach so enorm war. Aha, aber sehr groß. Und nach und nach haben sich dann eben wiederum die Städte einmal mehr Zentren des Handelns und der Kultur etabliert und genügend Reichtum akkumuliert, dass es dann eben zum Aufkommen der mittelalterlichen Stadt kommt, die wir bis heute kennen. Das ist jetzt von der Struktur her ein bisschen eine Mischung zwischen der sehr geordneten Stadt, die wir eben von Miletus kennen, und zwischen der absolut selbst organisierten Stadt, die wir davor hatten. Das heißt, es gab im Mittelalter eine gewisse Kraft von den Fürsten dagegen, die einen gewissen Druck ausgeübt hat, dass die Städte sich an bestimmte Gestaltungsprinzipien halten, dass die Häuser an einer Straße stehen und nicht irgendwo hingebaut wurden. Aber es gab nicht diese ganz rigide Struktur, dass es jetzt ein Straßenraster ist mit rechtwinkligen Kreuzungen. Und diese Städte, die kennen wir bis heute sehr gut, die werden oft dominiert von einem Marktplatz, da ging es um Handel, und von einer Kirche, Religion, und außenrum haben sich dann eben die einzelnen Häuser gruppiert und wurden dann oft noch zusätzlich von einer Stadtmauer geschützt. Und so im 15. und 16. Jahrhundert kam es dann zu einem starken Aufschwung der Städte als eben Handelspunkte. Da gab es ja auch viele Konflikte zwischen der Stadt und der Foidalherrschaft. Da gab es ja dieses geflügelte Wort, das Stadtluft frei macht, weil sich einige Städte eben das Recht erkämpft haben, unabhängig zu sein, ihr eigenes Geld zu prägen. Und das führte zu einer starken Expansion der Städte, und das ist vielleicht interessant und relevant bis heute, die eben sehr stark durch diese Stadtmauer definiert waren. Das heißt, die Städte haben sich ausgedehnt, bis sie in diese Mauer herangekommen sind, und dann verdichtet, verdichtet, verdichtet, weil eben niemand außerhalb der Mauer bauen wollte. Das ist zu gefährlich. Und das heißt, die Städte wurden extrem dicht, diese engen Gassen, bis es aus allen Nähten platzte. Und dann hat man diese Investitionen endlich getätigt, sagen, wir brauchen eine neue Stadtmauer, jetzt gehen wir davor. Und dann kam der nächste Ring dazu. Und diese einzelnen Ringe der Städte, die kann man auch oft bis heute beobachten. Das sind die einzelnen Phasen der Stadterweiterung. Das sieht man zum Beispiel in Moskau sehr gut. In Berlin auch, oder? Aber die Städte haben ja damals auch, diese mittelalterlichen Städte, man mag gar nicht dran denken, wie es da gerochen hat, aber so kanalisationstechnisch war das jetzt alles noch nicht ganz so auf römischem Standard wieder gekommen, oder? Ja, da gab es schreckliche Probleme. Da gab es immer wieder den Ausbruch von fürchterlichen Krankheiten, die ganzen Pestphasen, die dann einzelne Städte absolut von ihren Einwohnern befreit haben und eben auch andere Probleme wie Feuersbrünste. Das war natürlich ein Riesenthema, dass ganze Städte in Lirke brand sind und dann wieder aufgebaut werden mussten. Was man vielleicht noch sagen kann, ist, dass zur gleichen Zeit, wo in Europa zum 15., 16. Jahrhundert diese Feudalstruktur die Stadt definiert hat, mit diesen Gassen, halb geordnet, nicht geordnet, mit einer Stadtmauer außen rum, dass in Mittleren Osten wiederum ein anderes Modell der Stadt entstanden ist. Das ist die muslimische Stadt, die teilweise auch stark Europa wiederum beeinflusst hat, weil ja dann die Araber die ganze Mittelmeerküste besiedelt haben, von Nordafrika über Griechenland bis hin zu der südlichen Hälfte der Iberischen Halbinsel. Und da gab es wiederum eine ganz andere Idee von Stadt. Man könnte sagen, dass das gesellschaftliche System viel einfacher war, dass es sich komplett auf den Koran bezogen hat. Und deswegen gab es eine viel geringere Anzahl von kulturellen Institutionen. Es gab letztlich für das öffentliche Leben die Moschee. Und dann gab es noch den Hammam, also das Badehaus. Und zuletzt den Basar oder den Zug, das ist der Markt. Und der Rest war Wohnen. Und zusätzlich gab es dann noch die Residenz des jeweiligen lokalen Herrschers. Und die Stadt hat so funktioniert, dass sich der lokale Herrscher eigentlich gerne fernab von dem ganzen Chaos aufgehalten hat und auch gut geschützt war von Aufständigen und anderen Gefährlichkeiten. Und dass die Stadt selbst eben auch keinerlei öffentlichen Raum benötigt hat, weil eben das Leben viel privater, viel religiöser war. Und es gab deswegen gar nicht so dieses bunte Stadtleben und Plätze, was wir auch immer wieder aus irgendwelchen halb authentischen Filmen kennen, so vom Mittelalter, diese Mittelalter-Romantik, so mit dem Markt und der Gaukler und es geht total ab überall und der Dreck spritzt und die Huren stehen an der Ecke und alles. Und die arabische Stadt war ganz anders. Es gab keine Plätze und dann gab es eben ganz beeindruckend diesen einen Lehrraum in der Stadt und das war der Hof der Moschee. Also es gibt dann diese ganz engen Gassen, komplett chaotisch, weil auch wirklich jeder baut, wo er möchte. Das einzige Kriterium war, ich kann nicht so bauen, dass die anderen Häuser, die da stehen, dass die nicht mehr zu ihrer Wohnungstür kommen. Also es war sozusagen immer noch so gerade ein Stück Weg übrig. Und dann ist man eben in die Moschee reingegangen, der Innenhof der Moschee. Also das Innere war dann sozusagen das Äußere. Das war der öffentliche Raum. Das war dann plötzlich ein komplett geometrisch rechteckiger Platz. Ich bin selber in den Moscheen, in denen ich war, im Mittleren Osten sehr beeindruckt gewesen, weil dann auch noch der Boden, weil man ja den eben nur barfuß betreten kann, der ganze Boden eben wie glatt poliert von dem jahrhundertelangen, darüber laufenden, tausendernackter Füße. Das heißt, dass plötzlich nach diesen verwinkelten, schmutzigen Gassen ein spiegelblank polierten Steinboden und so eine gewisse Weite, die du sonst in der Stadt gar nicht findest. Und dann gab es noch den Basar, wo es eben um Handel geht. Und der Rest war dann einfach Chaos, was vielleicht auch viele militärische Vorteile hatte, weil sich eben mögliche Angreifer, falls sie die Stadtmauer überwunden haben, da eigentlich nur noch verirren konnten und dann in der nächsten Straßenecke verschwunden sind. Das wiederum hat natürlich bedeutet, dass das Inleben der Häuser viel wichtiger war als das Inleben der Häuser in der mittelalterlichen Stadt. In der mittelalterlichen Stadt, da hat sich das Leben auf der Straße abgespielt, da haben wir gerade von gesprochen. Deswegen waren die Häuser eher dunkel und unhygienisch. Das arabische Haus ist ganz anders. Das hat einen Brunnen im Hof des Hauses. Und dann hat man plötzlich im Hof des Hauses Dinge, die wir mit der Straße verbinden. Bäume, ein Brunnen, Tageslicht. Und da hat sich dann eben das eigene Gesellschaft gesehen. Ein kleines Idee, sozusagen, noch mal separat. Ich habe da noch mal eine private Theorie, dass ich dieses nach innen orientieren. Sicherlich auch, dass das Innleben auch darin begründet ist, da man ja gar nicht wirklich beeinflussen konnte, wo der Nachbar baut. Also es gab gar keine höhere Instanz, die kontrolliert hat, ob das jetzt irgendwie den Regulatorin oder dem allgemeinen Anstand entspricht, wie gebaut wird. Deswegen hat das arabische Haus einfach gar keine Außenfenster, weil nachher baut der Nachbar direkt davor sein Haus. Die Fenster gehen alle in den Innenhof, weil da ist sicher, das ist der kontrollierte Raum, da kann nichts passieren. Nach außen gibt es nur Brandmauern. Nach außen gibt es nur Brandmauern. Es ist sehr ungemütlich, durch eine klassisch arabische Stadt zu laufen und fremder zu sein. Man verläuft sich, es gibt nur Brandmauern, man hat keinerlei Öffnungen, es ist eigentlich sehr unfreundlich. Und man spürt auch, dass man in einem privaten Bereich irgendwie ist. Es gibt auch in der Arabstadt natürlich ein paar Hauptdurchwegungen, größere Straßen. Aber wenn man dann eben in die nächste Hierarchie-Ebene geht, in sein Stadtviertel hinein, dann hat man schon die erste Intimitätsverletzung begangen. Weil man, das ist zwar noch Straße nach unserem Begriff, aber es ist eigentlich schon ein erster Schritt des privaten Raumes dieser Nachbarschaft. Zum Beispiel bis heute in klassischen arabischen Vierteln kann es sein, dass sich die Frau unverschleiert in ihrem eigenen Stadtviertel bewegt, weil sie eben alle kennt. Das ist noch okay. Aber wenn dann plötzlich der Fremdling da reinkommt, dann ist es nicht mehr in Ordnung. Und deswegen wird man auch schon komisch angeguckt, wenn man dann plötzlich als fremder Tourist dann in so einen Seitenwesen reingeht. Ich hatte das mal, als ich in Marrakesch war, da gab es da auch irgendwie so unendliche Weiten. Und irgendwie hatte ich mich da nun mal total verlaufen. Und dann stand da nur noch so ein paar Schilder mit, hier eigentlich nur für Muselmanen. Da fühlte ich mich dann doch schon sehr unwohl. Immerhin aufgeschildert. Immerhin so. Das kannten die da schon so ein bisschen, dass die Touristen da irgendwie drin verlaufen. Ja, das ist der Grund. Ja, das heißt, okay, das ist ein interessanter Blickwinkel. Das heißt, diese Stadtstruktur des muslimischen war irgendwie mehr so privat parceliert. Das Private schottete sich irgendwie ab und dort fand dann aber sozusagen das kulturelle Leben, aber auch in einem familiären oder großfamiliären Kreis statt, zu Ungunsten einer Gesamtbegegnung im öffentlichen Raum, was ja dann, wenn man dieser kreativen Stadt-These dann nochmal folgen möchte, ja den Nachteil hatte für diese Gesellschaften, dass sie eben dann eben nicht so viel kreatives Potenzial und Neuerung erfahren haben. Man möchte meinen, dass dann an einem geschichtlichen Verlauf auch ablesen zu können. Ja, da muss man, das ist richtig, aber gleichzeitig muss man aufpassen, da die muslimische Stadt oder die muslimische Kultur nicht als homogenen Block zu sehen. Da gab es natürlich ganz andere Zeiten. Ich denke gerade zu Zeiten, als die Kolonialisierung der iberischen Halbinsel stattfand, als die Araber dort waren, war die arabische Welt der Zenit der europäischen Kultur. Die hatten die besten Astronomen, die hatten die besten Ärzte, die hatten die besten Künstler, die haben die Mathematik ganz weit nach vorne gebracht. Wir benutzen die arabischen Zahlen, wir sagen Al-Gebra, das ist natürlich arabisch, Al-Gebra. Von rechts nach links die Zahlen. Die Araber benutzen übrigens die indischen Zahlen heutzutage, das ist auch ganz interessant, da gibt es so eine Verschiebung nach Westen. Wie passt das dann zusammen? Was fördert die Stadt sozusagen an der Stelle? Ja, und das waren eben einfach sehr offene Kulturen. Also das wollte ich sagen, das ist einfach kein homogener Block, wo man jetzt sagt, dass die arabische Stadt, die arabische Gesellschaft immer generell fundamental religiös, sehr pur auf den Koran ausgelegt war. Nein, nein, zum Beispiel in der großen Moschee von Aleppo, wo ich auch öfters war, da haben über Jahrhunderte hinweg Christen und Muslime einfach gemeinsam gebetet. Ja, wir haben einen Gott und wir mixen das hier alles und wir handeln auch zusammen und deswegen beten wir natürlich auch zusammen. Und das war gar kein Ding. Also das ist heute ein größeres Problem, als nicht Muslim in die Moschee zu gehen, als es vor 900 Jahren war. Das muss man sich immer wieder klarmachen, dass es da verschiedene Zeiten gab. Und da gab es natürlich auch Künstler und da gab es natürlich auch gesellschaftliches Leben in dem Sinn. Aber prinzipiell, wenn man jetzt die klassische arabische religiöse Stadt sieht, ist es ein anderes Gesellschaftsbild, das viel weniger eben kulturelle Dinge hervorbringt. Das sieht man auch bis... Es ist gefährlich, das jetzt sozusagen. Aber man sieht ja bis heute diese Konflikte, die man dann in Afghanistan immer wieder sieht, dass die Taliban die Radios einsammeln, weil das eben nicht dem der Essenz des Koran entspricht. Dieses Bilderverbot zum Beispiel. Natürlich ist die skulpturale und malerische Entwicklung in gewisser Weise eingefroren, wenn es einfach dieses Bildnisverbot gibt. Auf der anderen Seite gab es dann unglaubliche andere künstlerische Entwicklungen, wenn es um diese ganzen Pattern, um diese Muster geht und um diese Einlegearbeiten. Das hat sich dann einfach in einen anderen Kanal gesucht. Genau, diese Energie. So, jetzt sind wir ja schon ein bisschen weiter. Also ich meine, diese Mittelalter- Entwicklung der Städte in Europa und auch diese arabische Entwicklung, das war ja eine relativ parallele Entwicklung, die sich auch gar nicht groß gegenseitig beeinflusst hat. Richtig, also es gab natürlich viele Berührungspunkte, wie gesagt eben in Spanien und auch in der Türkei und bis hoch zu Österreich, aber die nächsten großen Schritte, wo sich was verändert hat, waren eigentlich der Barock, da gab es vielleicht noch so die Renaissance-Stadt in Italien zwischendurch und dann gab es so, ich denke das war 16. Jahrhundert, die Barocke Stadt, wo es wiederum ein Wandel des Weltbildes gab, das sich wiederum in der Stadt wieder gespiegelt hat und dann ist es auch nicht mehr weit hin zur Industrialisierung, die alles verändert hat und letztlich zu der modernen Stadt geführt hat. Aber welchen Wandel des Weltbildes würdest du da anführen? Ja, in Barock gab es wiederum die Idee, dass das absoluten Herrschers und einer sehr geordneten Welt. Es gab diese ganzen Modelle der einzelnen Sphären, der Himmelsordnung und diese Himmelsordnung hat sich dann eben auch wiederum auf der Erde wieder gespiegelt, zum Beispiel in der Stadt. Und deswegen gibt es dann Anlagen wie Versailles. Dann gibt es plötzlich eine Idee, dass es einen Plan gibt, nachdem sich die Stadt entwickelt hat. Das sind nicht mehr so Einzelinitiativen, wo jetzt da ein reicher Herr irgendwie sein Palast baut an einer Straße und daraus entsteht dann das Bild der Stadt wie eine Collage, sondern plötzlich gibt es ein Gesamtbild mit einer Hauptachse und zwei anderen Achsen, die im 30-Grad-Winkel auf den genau runden Platz führen. Und in dem Zentrum des runden Platzes steht die Säule und wenn man sich umdreht, sieht man oben auf dem Hügel den Palast des Fürsten, der genau symmetrisch in der Mitte sitzt. Das war eben die barocke Stadt, wo es ganz viel um diese Achsen ging und um die Kompositionen. Kann man sagen, dass da eigentlich dieser Begriff Stadtplanung überhaupt das erste Mal wirklich so zum Leben erweckt wird? Weil bisher hat sich das ja alles mehr oder weniger entwickelt, wenn man jetzt mal in unserem Bereich bleiben. Du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, China etc. Die haben das gleich von Anfang an ganz anders gesehen, aber jetzt mal mit unserem eurozentristischen Blick betrachtet. Naja, wir hatten die Griechen, die da so ein bisschen die Anomalie waren und die Römer, die ganz klar geplant haben. Das stimmt. Also dann kam es wieder. Dann kam es wieder, in den moderneren Kontext. Jetzt, ohne das Mittelalter zu überspringen, ist da Stadtplanung wieder aufgekommen. Da haben wir eben auch ganz herausragende Beispiele, wie eben Bienenbarockeanlagen oder wie Paris, wo man das ganz oft sieht, wie die Achsen eben die Stadt definieren. In Paris... Paris erschlägt einen das, finde ich. Ja, in Paris hatte dann auch noch mal sozusagen eine Renaissance, diese Idee. Da gab es 1850 Baron Haussmann, also das ist wieder etwas später, 250 Jahre später, der eben diese großen Achsen, die man bis heute kennt, in Paris geschlagen hat. Das war ein radikaler Stadtplaner. Haussmann hat eben und die Motivation war da sicherlich auch eher hygienisch und politisch motiviert, dieses Stadtbild radikal verändert. Da ging es wieder, was du vorhin angesprochen hattest, um eineseits um Krankheiten, die sich verbreitet haben. Aber es ging auch ganz klar um das Unterkontrolle-Halten der Bevölkerung. Weil man kann eben viel schlechter eine mittelalterliche Stadt kontrollieren, wo es verwinkelte Gassen gibt, als man eine Stadt kontrollieren kann, in der es ein paar klare breite Achsen gibt, wo man aufmarschieren kann. Da hat man einfach mehr Übersicht. Und da hat eben Hausmann radikal auch sehr rücksichtslos die Stadt verändert, indem ganze Stadtteile abreißen lassen, um dann eben Schneisen zu schlagen, die wir bis heute erkennen und die eben heute Paris ausmachen. Die auch wirklich fantastisch sind. Die fantastisch sind und da ist auch viel Fantastisches verloren gegangen, aber das ist eben auch Wandel der Stadt und das fällt mir immer wieder ein, wenn man die Diskussionen in Berlin heutzutage verfolgt, wo dann eben auf der einen Seite ganz vorsichtig erklärt wird, das geht doch nicht, das ist die Geschichte, da können wir nichts verändern, das ist ein Glashochhaus, das geht doch nicht, das steinende Berlin. Manchmal ist eben so ein radikaler Schnitt notwendig, aber manchmal ist es vielleicht eben auch zu viel. Da muss man im Einzelfall abwägen, da gibt es kein Rezept. Die Stadt ist eben permanent im Wandel, das ist vielleicht so ein Bon-Mod, das man auf jeden Fall unterschreiben kann. Ja, ich bring dich ein bisschen ab vom Weg hier. Also wir waren beim Barock und der Wiederentdeckung der Stadtplanung, die sich dann überall in Europa im Prinzip manifestiert hat. Da war so diese ganze Vergöttlichung der Herrscher sicherlich schon mal ganz hilfreich, da interessante Modelle hervorzubringen. Und ich habe aber dann auch so den Eindruck, dass das ist dann aber auch so für ein paar Jahrhunderte dann auch so das Modell gewesen, was sich eigentlich fortgesetzt hat, oder? Ja, es kam dann relativ bald von 17. und 18. Jahrhundert zur Industrialisierung. Eben wieder eine Technische Innovation, die die gesamte Gesellschaft verändert hat. Und hinzu kommt noch der Wandel vielleicht des feudalen Systems zu einem eher bürgerlichen System, was auch in dem gleichen Zeitraum politisch und gesellschaftlich stattfand. Und die Industrialisierung hat eben, da gibt es unglaubliche Bilder aus Manchester und so im 18. Jahrhundert, hat eben zu einer absoluten Verslammung der europäischen Städte geführt, zu einer Ausbeutung der Arbeiterklasse. Das ist immer, ich springe jetzt auch wieder, das ist immer ganz interessant, wenn man heute nach, sagen wir, Afrika geht und versucht, die Probleme von dort städtischen Slums zu lösen und auch in Südamerika, wenn man sich die Favelas anguckt, die du vielleicht auch in Sao Paulo irgendwie am Rande gesehen hast, dass halt die europäischen Städte, die wir heute haben, die tollen europäischen Städte, in Fonoa 250 Jahren oft ganz genauso aussahen. Keinelei Infrastruktur, die, damit meine ich keine frisches Wasser, Leute, die zur Arbeit gependelt sind in Fabriken und unter den Menschen und würdigsten Verhältnissen überhaupt gearbeitet haben, um dann wieder zurück in ihr kleines Loch zu ziehen und dort irgendwie zu überleben. Und das ist auch ganz wichtig, sich diese Verhältnisse vor Augen zu führen, um sich danach die Ideen, die in der frühen Moderne entwickelt wurden, zu verstehen. Weil es dann eben plötzlich Ideen gab wie Funktionstrennung. Wir müssen an einem anderen Ort leben, an dem wir arbeiten, als an dem wir arbeiten. Über diese Ideen sind wir ja schon wieder hinweg. Wir haben eben verstanden mit der kreativen Stadt, dass es gerade diese Durchmischung braucht, wo wir heute sind, dass es nicht funktioniert hat. Aber deswegen haben wir bis hin in die 60er, 70er diese Ideen von dem Wohnen in der Wohngegend, dem Gewerbegebiet und dann noch woanders ist so das Stadtzentrum, wo man so einkaufen geht und zwischendurch fährt man mit dem Auto. Natürlich war das erstmal das Ideal, weil man dieses Bild hat vom Wohnen in Grün mit der frischen Luft und den Bäumen, wenn man vor Augen hat die verdreckten Zustände und das totale Chaos der Stadt des 18. Jahrhunderts. Dann wollte man natürlich plötzlich das Radikal ändern. Hat nur begrenzt funktioniert? Hat nur begrenzt funktioniert. Jetzt schreiten wir mit großen Schritten voran, aber da gab es vielleicht zwei, drei Namen, die man unbedingt erwähnen muss. Zum einen gab es den sogenannten Siam-Kongress. Das war der Kongress International der Architektur Modern, also der internationale Kongress der modernen Architektur. Das war eine Kongressreihe, die im frühen 20. Jahrhundert bis in die 60er Jahre stattgefunden hat. Das war eine Denkfabrik für moderne Stadtplanung, aber auch eben Architektur-Ideen. Da ist auf jeden Fall eine Schlüssefabrik Le Corbusier, aber da waren noch viele deutsche Vertreter der frühen Architektur Moderne. Ah, Französisch. Genau, Kongress. International d'architecture moderne. Siam. Corbusier mittendrin und das war dann sozusagen die Geburt des Hochhauses. Das war die Geburt der funktionalen Trennung, was für die Stadtplaner so das Ding war und gleichzeitig die, sagen wir, der Glaube an den technischen Fortschritt, der zu der Zeit noch ungebrochen war, bis in die 60er und eben die Idee des Automobils und die glorifizierende Bewegung, dass eben die Bewegung und der Zug und das Zeppelin, weißt du, das waren so die Dinge, woran geglaubt wurde. Und das ist natürlich auch ein radikales anderes Stadtbild. Also da gibt es so ganz poetische Texte auch von einer Bewegung, die in Italien sehr stark von den Futuristen, wo dann eben so Gedichte auf die Bewegung im Automobil verfasst wurden. Das war so das Höchste. Und heute sind wir wieder so, ja heute mögen wir das Mittelalter Chaos eher. Das ist ja gerade eher so ein romantisches Bild von Stadt, das gerade wieder innen ist. Und damals war es so, wir sausen, Kraftwerk fast, wir sausen über die Autobahn. Kraftwerk ist ja schon eher eine kritische Reflektion dessen gewesen. Genau, genau. Wenn man das nicht ironisch nimmt, sondern wir fahren, fahren, fahren auf der Autobahn. Darum ging es eigentlich auch ganz stark. Bei Siam. Und diese Ideen wurden dann auch umgesetzt, oft waren die, was kann man vielleicht so sagen, die Köpfe, die in Siam dabei waren, sehr hervorragend und haben auch oft hervorragende Bauwerke hinterlassen. Und oft wurden diese Ideen dann auch nicht ganz adäquat bis in die 70er umgesetzt. Also es wurde moderne Städte geplant auf Theorien, die vielleicht theoretisch gut funktioniert haben, aber in der Umsetzung dann gescheitert sind. Es waren eben zu perfekte Modelle von Gesellschaft wiederum. Das kann man auch durch die Geschichte immer wieder beobachten. Wenn der Planer versucht, zu genau festzulegen, wie die Stadt funktionieren soll, dann geht das auch nur mit einem ganz bestimmten Modell, wie die Menschen sich verhalten. Und wenn sich die Menschen dann anders verhalten, dann bricht das ganze Kartenhaus zusammen. Und das sieht man dann immer wieder. Und deswegen wiederum, was wir ganz am Anfang hatten, funktionieren diese Gründerzeitbauten in Berlin so gut, weil die Gesellschaft wandelt sich und anscheinend kann man da auch als WG drin wohnen oder eben ein Büro drin haben. Und diese Flexibilität ist eben extrem wichtig. Und die Moderne, die hat ganz anders funktioniert. Da ging es eben darum, sehr spezifisch die effizientesten Modelle zu finden für Arbeiten, für sich bewegen. Das geht hin bis zur Organisation der Küche. Da gibt es die berühmte Frankfurter Küche, wo eine Architektengruppe genau festgelegt hat, was so die Bewegungsabläufe der modernen Hausfrau sind. Und dann wurde eben die Einbauküche erfunden und so abgestimmt, dass halt die Frau sich möglichst wenig beim Herstellen eines klassischen deutschen Gerichtes bewegen musste. Das war dann alles optimiert. Das Arbeitsdreieck. Das Arbeitsdreieck. Und ja, da ging dann sozusagen so eine gewisse Überraschung oder das Unvorhergesehene, das Unerwartete im Stadtbild vielleicht verloren. Und das hat auch ganz auf zu desaströsen Umständen wiederum geführt. Das war ja wirklich ein massiver Wandel, weil ja dann denke ich auch so im Zuge der Industrialisierung die Menschheit ja auch gelernt hatte, dass wenn sie jetzt mal eine neue Idee hatte, sie dann auch gleich massenhaft zum Einsatz zu bringen. Und das bezog sich natürlich genauso auch auf die Architektur. Gerade das Bauen von Gebäuden hat ja enorm davon profitiert, in Anführungsstrichen, dass eben dieser technische Fortschritt möglich war. Die Maschinen erlaubten auf einmal, das Transportieren von großen Mengen in die Höhe, entsprechend schossen die Gebäude in die Höhe und mussten nicht 300 Jahre lang Stein für Stein aufeinander errichtet werden, sondern das Ganze ging dann ratze fatze. Und dann hat man sich natürlich dann auch in der Stadtplanung schnell dahin verirrt, eben so riesige Monstersiedlungen zu machen, die so einem Idealbild folgten. Das heißt, man sah sich in zunehmendem Maße dann auch gerade bei so Freunden wie Le Corbusier doch in dieser Situation, dass da so ein Idealbild einer Gesellschaft zementiert wurde im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und später stellte man dann erst fest, hm, funktioniert vielleicht doch nicht so gut. Richtig. Und das ist eben vor allem auf dem Maßstab der Stadt zu verstehen, weil eben diese Idealbilder als Stadt nie funktioniert haben. Da kann man noch mal vielleicht einen ganz kurzen Exkurs in Stadtutopien machen, die auch alle immer wieder gescheitert sind. Also das Wort Utopia, das heißt nicht Ort in Griechisch, ist eben entstanden in der Literatur. Thomas Moros, 1546, glaube ich, hat ja im Ufer fast das eben auch Utopia heißt. Es spricht von der Reise eines Einzelnen zu einer Insel, wo er die ideale Gesellschaft wiederum entdeckt. Und dann ist die Stadt auch sehr stark gegliedert, wie die Gesellschaft funktioniert, in vier einzelne Bereiche usw. Das hat dann im 16. Jahrhundert zu einer Vielzahl von Idealstädten, die entworfen wurden, geführt. Da gab es Christianopolis, die Stadt für den idealen Christen, wo die einzelnen Berufsgruppen in bestimmten Straßen usw. gewohnt haben. Da gab es andere Modelle. Und im 17. Jahrhundert wurden die Modelle teilweise umgesetzt. Da gibt es ein Modell, das heißt Falence d'Air. Da muss ich auch kurz mal nachgucken, wer das überhaupt entwickelt hat. Genau, das war von Charles Fourier, der gelebt hat eben auch im 18. Jahrhundert. Und das ist sozusagen ein großes Gebäude, eine Phalanx, in der genau 1620 Menschen leben. Und die Menschen sollten dort gemeinsam leben, lieben, arbeiten und konsumieren. Bestandteil des Konzepts war die freie Liebe, sagt Wikipedia hier. Und das sollte dann eben auch der Palast, das wäre es sei, für den normalen Arbeiter sein. Aber mit diesem Wohnmodell ging eben wiederum ein ganz bestimmtes Verhalten und Arbeitsmodell einher. Und diese Dinge wurden dann auch gebaut im 18. Jahrhundert und sind natürlich immer gescheitert, weil am Ende die Menschen nicht so perfekt waren und nicht so frei von Eigensucht und Eifersucht oder wo auch immer die Modelle passiert haben, gelöhnt sind und was anderes passiert ist. Das ist alles gescheitert. Und genauso, um zurück zu moderner zu kommen, genauso war das natürlich auch bei der modernen Stadt. Die Moderne hat hervorragende einzelne Gebäude hervorgebracht. Es gibt großartige Bauwerke von Corbusier, von Mies van der Rohe, von Gropius, die auch wirklich diese neue Ästhetik zeigen. Und da gibt es auch fantastische Fortschritte, dass eben jetzt in der Architektur ein neues Bild von Schönheit oder von Proportionen. Also da haben wir zum Beispiel das Satteldach verloren, da ist dann das Flachdach aufgekommen. Da gibt es diese weiße Architektur der Moderne, die so eher kubistisch ist. Da sind große Werke entstanden, aber wenn man das wiederum sieht auf der Ebene der Stadt, kann man immer wieder sagen, dass Entwürfe, die jetzt irgendwie imposant und großartig wirken, als Stadt fast nie funktionieren. Jetzt fange ich fast schon wieder an, über meine eigene Arbeit zu reden, weil... Ich auch nicht funktionieren. Weil ich mit denen immer wieder konfrontiert werde. Weil, genau, gute Stadtplanung, guter Städtebau ist sehr schwer zu verkaufen, weil das, was auf den Bildern großartig aussieht, jetzt die groß angelegte Achse, wo alles symmetrisch ist, wo alles perfekt ist, was so dem Auge, was so leicht verständlich ist, das ist eigentlich immer die Stadt, die scheitert. Wie eben bei Le Corbusier, die Ville Radieuse, wo alles so kreuzförmige Gebäude in einem Raster sind, die Idealstadt, das scheitert. Das, was funktioniert, sieht einfach nicht gut aus. Das, was funktioniert, ist einfach sehr komplex, sehr durcheinander. Natürlich gibt es da einzelne Zentren, natürlich gibt es Höhepunkte, aber es gibt einfach oft kein einzelnes, übergeordnetes Ordnungsprinzip. Da gibt es immer wieder Versuche und das scheitert immer. Und das sieht man bis heute. Da kann man gucken, da kann man nach Dubai gucken, wo jetzt eigentlich gerade in den letzten Jahren wiederum versucht wurde, so eine Stadt zu entwickeln, die vor allem für Google Earth-Besucher beeindruckend aussieht, mit der Palme, die Palmeinsel und so weiter. Und das scheitert natürlich alles. Die Dinger stehen alle leer, die Buchten versanden, es mief, keiner will es mehr kaufen, es gibt nur eine Zugangsstraße, die immer verstopft ist. Es ist ein Desaster in jeglicher Hinsicht, ökonomisch, ökologisch und so weiter, weil wiederum sein Bild versucht wurde, zu implementieren. Und das ist eine Diskussion, die da immer wieder auftaucht. Interessant. Ich habe das nur gesehen, als das noch im Bau war, da bin ich da mal rübergeflogen. Dubai ist schon eine Stadt, die einem irgendwie Angst einjagt, gerade in dieser planerischen Hinsicht, weil man sieht so, wow, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie alles in drei Jahren entstanden, so eine Fläche, wo man hier auch mal ein paar tausend Jahre für gebraucht hat, die zu füllen. Und man merkt auch schnell, alles wird dann gleich im gleichen Stil gebaut. Manchmal braucht es wohl auch einfach die Zeit, einfach auch etwas mal zu testen, dass es eine Weile überdauert, sich bewährt, bevor man eben anfängt, es zu kopieren. Und wenn es eben zu schnell geht, dann kauft man sich schnell so eine Homogenität ein und das nicht selten eben mit etwas, was dann eben, wo alle feststellen, so naja, also eigentlich finden wir das jetzt wieder schön, noch funktioniert es gut. Und dann wird es eben auch gleich verslammt. Ja, siehst du, du bist auch schon fast Stadtplaner. Man merkt das schon. Das sind zwei Stunden ungefähr reichen. Demnächst alle, die hier zuhören. Das war ja das Ziel. Weil du hast gerade wirklich die fast schon die wichtigsten Punkte, die ich auch mal wieder versuche zu fördern und im Rahmen dieser Vereinten Nationen Arbeit zu präsentieren. Du hast ja gleich ganz am Anfang schon ein paar Zauberworte gesagt, nicht so die chaotische Entwicklung auf der einen Seite und die voll geplante auf der anderen Seite. Und man merkt eigentlich beiden Modellen an, dass sie eben irgendwie, wenn sie nur für sich alleine existieren, eigentlich keine Chance haben. Das Chaos führt halt irgendwie genau eben in das und alles, was eben von oben so top-down geplant wird, das greift eben auch nicht. Ich sehe auch extrem viele Parallelen, deswegen interessiert mich dieses Thema Stadtplanung eigentlich auch schon immer irgendwie, auch wenn ich mich jetzt nicht sehr intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt habe. Aber das ist so eine Perspektive, die ich auch gerne eröffne für mich, jetzt, wenn ich mir andere Städte, Strukturen und Länder anschaue, dass man eben da auch interessante Parallelen hat, zum Beispiel zur Software-Entwicklung, wo du auch zwar viel Planung brauchst, aber auch so einen gewissen organischen Bestandteil berücksichtigen muss und das zumindest eine Weile gut verfolgen musst, um zu schauen, was eben auch wirklich durchhält, dann in der realen Benutzung eben, wenn die Software dann draußen ist. Das ist ja eigentlich die Melange aus Chaos und Planung letztlich das Zaubermittel nur sein kann. Die Gewichtung, wie viel lassen wir hier einen natürlichen Entwicklungsraum und wie implementieren wir Systeme, diese natürliche Entwicklung vielleicht auch in irgendeiner Form in die Planung zurückfließen zu lassen und wo ist einfach eben auch eine Planung unerlässlich. Richtig, also die Parallele funktioniert ganz gut. Es geht eben, was du gesagt hast, das ist so eine Flexibilität in der Entwicklung gibt und dass man eben nicht versucht, das Riesenprojekt auf einmal fertigzustellen, wie in der Softwareplanung. Da gibt es genügend Projekte, wo jahrzehntelang programmiert wird und dann wird released und es funktioniert halt einfach nicht. Genauso ist es mit diesen New Towns, die eben auf dem Reisbrett entstanden sind oft. Und auf der anderen Seite, dass man mit Pilotprojekten eben immer wieder testet, was funktioniert, was nicht funktioniert, was adaptiert werden kann und dann versucht daraus zu lernen und eben die Stadt so kontinuierlich weiterzuentwickeln. Das sind eigentlich die Methoden. Und wenn man jetzt, natürlich gibt es Kontexte, in denen man sehr radikal, sehr schnell, sehr viele Quadratmeter einfach herstellen muss. Das war eben so im 18. Jahrhundert in Europa, wo Städte wie Barcelona und auch Berlin unglaublich schnell um Hunderttausende, wenn nicht Millionen, gewachsen sind. So sind hier die Gründerzeit. Die ganze Breslauer Berggrube gerade sitzen. Genau und da wurde dann einfach so ein Konzept eben durchgezogen und genauso in Barcelona auch. Und was dann aber wiederum interessant ist, dass oft die Modelle, die am trockensten sind, die dann von Hubrecht in Berlin, Hubrecht war ein Abwasseringenieur, der hat Berlin zu verantworten. In Barcelona war es Serdar. Das war auch ein Ingenieur, kein Künstler, kein Architekt, kein Stadtplaner, der dieses Straßengrid entworfen hat. Und dass dann die Modelle, die sozusagen sehr einfach gehalten sind, dann eben sehr flexibel, sich als sehr flexibel erwiesen haben und bis heute zu funktionieren. Ein anderes gutes Beispiel ist Manhattan in New York. Da haben halt einfach die Siedler ganz am Anfang das Stück in lauter einzelner Rechtecke unterteilt, das Stück Land, was sie da hatten. Die haben nicht an Hochhäuser gedacht. Die haben daran gedacht, dass da jeder sein Häuschen drauf hat und außenrum ein bisschen Land. Und dieses Manhattan-Grid ist halt einfach bis heute erfolgreich durch diese Simplicität, in dem Fall durch die Flexibilität, dass da eben alles Mögliche drauf passieren kann auf diesem generischen Stück Land. Auch wenn es ein bisschen langweilig ist? Auch wenn es ein bisschen langweilig ist, aber dann können wiederum andere Dinge passieren, die sehr interessant sind. Also da ist man ja fast wieder bei so einem Pixel-Grid, wo dann der einzelne Pixel alles Mögliche sein kann. Dann gibt es dann halt mal einen Bruch im System. Das ist dann der OK, das ist dann der Broadway. Und dann gibt es mal den Central Park, der jetzt auch nicht als Park fürs Volk geplant war, sondern das war ein Wasserreservoir für die Bevölkerung ursprünglich. Und plötzlich erfüllt es sich dann eben wieder mit Leben. Also da gibt es so einzelne Bausteine eigentlich für die Stadt. Und wenn man die irgendwie einigermaßen hinkriegt, dann hat man schon eine recht gute Stadt. Und dann kann man vielleicht ambitioniert werden und noch Dinge hinzufügen. Aber man braucht einfach ausreichend Raum für die Straße. Das hört sich jetzt banal an, aber das ist gerade in viel schnell wachsenden Städten in Südostasien oder in Afrika eine ganz problematische Frage. Man braucht genügend Raum reserviert für öffentlichen Raum. Und dann können eigentlich die Leute auf dem Platz oft machen, was sie wollen. Und das wird eine Stadt, die recht gut ist. Die Probleme entstehen oft eher, wenn man wiederum versucht, zu viel zu planen, das zu zonieren, wenn man arbeiten und wohnen, dass man versucht, das auseinander zu dehnen, dass man zu sehr kontrolliert. Oder die Probleme entstehen, wenn man eben überhaupt nicht führt. Also die komplett ungeheimte Entwicklung führt dann eben oft zu Slums. Und die komplett überrationale Stadt führt dann oft zu einem amerikanischen Modell von Business Center, CBD, Central Business District, Wohnen außerhalb mit all den ökologischen und Raumproblemen, die das eben mit sich bringt. Also das haben wir jetzt schon fast in der kontemporären Diskussion von verschiedenen Stadtmodellen angekündigt. Ja, aber bleiben wir doch mal ein bisschen so in der moderne, du hast ja Corbusier genannt, mit seinen Hochhäusern und so weiter, sicherlich vielen bekannt, auch mit seinem Sessel. Mir fällt da noch ein anderer Name ein, nämlich Oskar Niemeyer. Der ist ja sicherlich zumindest ein bisschen auch mit in diese Kategorie zu zählen, deutscher Name, aber halt Brasilianer und unter anderem ja auch zumindest partiell mitverantwortlich für die große Architektur, die sich dort in vielen Städten findet. Er hat ja auch seine Finger mit im Spiel bei der Planung von Brasília, die ja im Prinzip, ich weiß nicht, ist das nicht überhaupt so das Beispiel für hier so der Führerbaut im Klo, eine Stadt. Also wir machen jetzt mal hier so im Nichts, eine Stadt, das gab's jetzt auch noch in anderen, was ist die, Usbekistan oder... Es gibt so paar Beispiele. Gibt's immer mal wieder, aber Brasília ist glaube ich das bekannteste. Da war ja vorher im Wesentlichen gar nichts. Richtig. Es gibt so ein Genre von Stadt, das im Allgemeinen als New Town bezeichnet wird. Also die New Town ist die Stadt, die im Nichts geplant entstanden ist. Wir haben sogar in Europa Beispiele, sogar recht junge. Das ist zum Beispiel Almere in Holland. Amsterdam ist aus allen Nähten geplatzt und dann ist daneben Almere entstanden. Aber gehen wir erstmal zurück zu Niemeyer und Louis Costa und darf da nicht unerwähnt bleiben. Oskar Niemeyer ist ganz klar einer der Hauptfiguren der Moderne. Er spielt insofern eine gewisse Sonderrolle. Also er ist auch Zeitgenosse von Le Corbusier. Le Corbusier ist glaube ich etwas älter und es gab aber immer so eine Wechselwirkung zwischen den beiden. Das ist ganz interessant. Die sind sich oft begegnet und an diesen Kreuzungspunkten hat sich dann immer die Arbeit auch wirklich verändert, nachdem die sich begegnet sind. Niemeyer ist besonders, weil er der Vertreter der Moderne war, der es geschafft hat, der Rationalität der Architektur mit den klaren Linien so eine gewisse Poesie einzuhauchen. Also Niemeyer, wenn man politisch korrekt ist, dann sagt man, dass Niemeyer inspiriert war von den sich entlangschlängelnden Linien der Küste von Rio, wo er dann eben auch sein Büro hatte und über den Strand, über die Copacabana geblickt hat. Aber Niemeyer selbst sagt eigentlich immer wieder, dass er eher von den Linien der Weiblichkeit inspiriert ist, als von den Linien der Küste. Also er hat es immer wieder geschafft, so eine sehr fast sensuelle, erotische, menschliche Linie in diese Moderne hineinzubringen und in den Werken, wo sich diese zwei Dinge am radikalsten treffen. Also diese Klarheit und die Rationalität und diese Menschlichkeit und die Poesie, das sind eigentlich die besten Werke. Er ist in seinem Spätwerk noch viel figuraler, skulpturaler geworden und das ist fast schon wieder schwächer, weil es diese Spannung nicht gibt. Aber da reden wir über Architektur und Niemeyer ist und bleibt auch Architekt. Er hat ein paar größere Masterplan-artige Projekte gemacht, die dann eher Prinzipien der Moderne folgen. Da muss ich auch noch ganz kurz in den Exkurs einschieben, weil es gibt, sagen wir, zwei verschiedene Ansätze, wie man Raum versteht, wenn wir jetzt sozusagen in die Ausbildung des Stadtplaners gehen. Die klassische Idee ist, dass der Raum definiert ist durch seine Kanten und dass sich in der klassischen europäischen Stadt eben Straßen und Plätze und Orte dadurch definieren, dass sie sozusagen das sind, wo nicht gebaut ist. Also der Platz ist sozusagen die Leere und dadurch entsteht die Stadt aus der Addition dieser einzelnen Figuren. Die Moderne vertritt ein radikal anderes Verständnis von Raum. Das ist natürlich wiederum auch inspiriert aus der Kunst. Du brauchst nur an die Kubisten oder an Pete Mondrian denken, an die abstrakte Malerei, dass man so zeigen, die tabula rasa hat, die leere weiße Fläche und darauf komponiert man dann einzelne Objekte. Das ist dann so ein Figurgrundspiel und dadurch entsteht der Raum. Und so sind dann sehr bekannte Ensembles der Moderne entstanden. Zum Beispiel der MIT Campus von Mies van der Rohe, eine Komposition von einzelnen Gebäuden. Oder auch, und da kommen wir gleich zu Brasilia, oder auch einzelne Gegengebiete in Brasilia. Oder auch, zum Beispiel, das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel für einen Newtown in Chandigarh. Das ist so das hauptrealisierte Städtebauwerk von Le Corbusier im Gegensatz zu den unrealisierten Projekten. Die werden Chandigarh, das ist in Indien. Gut, das heißt, Luis Costa hat gemeinsam mit der Unterstützung von Oscar Niemeyer Brasilien entstanden. Und das sollte eben die neue Hauptstadt des Landes Brasilien werden. Auch im Zentrum des Landes, nicht an der Küste, wo sich sonst eben das ganze Leben abgespielt hat. Und das ist komplett eine, auf dem Reißbrett entstandene Idealstadt. Sehr interessant ist aber auch sicherlich durch den Einfluss von Oscar Niemeyer, dass der Grundriss ein bisschen einem Vogel ändert oder wenn man möchte, ähnelt. Oder wenn man möchte, einem abhebenen Flugzeug. Also da ist schon wieder dieser, sagen wir, dieses poetische Element. So eine geborene Linie, nicht einfach nur gerade, sondern schmiegt sich da ja auch an so ein See an. Ich weiß nicht, ist der künstlich oder gab es den zumindest schon vorher? Ich glaube, der ist auf jeden Fall geformt, dass das so ins Ensemble passt. Aber natürlich, es ist eine Stadt, wo die Straßen breit sind. Das ist eine Stadt, die für das Auto gemacht ist. Es ist eine Stadt, die einem immer wieder neue Blicke auf die unglaublichen Architekturen von Oskar Niemeyer erlaubt. Was allerdings sehr interessant ist, immer wieder ist bei diesen Idealstädten, wie die letztlich von den Nutzern, wie die Nutzer sich diese Städte aneignen, weil sie eben nicht so funktionieren, wie sie ursprünglich gedacht sind. Und da gibt es, da findet man hervorragende Beispiele, wie dann plötzlich in dem Abstandsgrünen zwischen den zwei Spuren der Autobahn dazwischen, wie dann dann plötzlich Reis gepflanzt wird, von den Leuten, die in der Nähe wohnen. Weil die wollen halt nicht immer fünf Kilometer fahren, die haben kein Auto, die sind zu arm. Oder wie unter einem der grandiosen Autobahnbrücken von Niemeyer Costa, die Leute so Wäschelinien entspannen und ihre Wäsche aufhängen. Das hatten die bestimmt nicht im Sinn. Aber das macht eigentlich damit den ganzen Charme der Stadt aus, dass die Leute sich dann doch immer wieder rangieren, die Stadt verändern. Um wieder jetzt ganz klar in die in die in die in die Jetztzeit zu springen, da sieht man auch wieder ein Beispiel von einer Idealstadt, die sich gerade im Bau befindet. Das ist Mastar City, das ist auch in den Emiraten. Und Mastar, M-A-S-D-A-R, ist eine gerade in Planung oder im Bau befindliche Ökostadt in der Nähe von Abu Dhabi, geplant von Norman Foster. Gemeinsam natürlich mit einem größeren Team, wo eben auch alles ganz klar nach ökologischen Kriterien durchplant ist. Sehr gut, sehr intelligent in vielerlei Hinsicht. Die Straßen sind endlich wieder mal eng genug, sodass sie verschattet sind, was in der klimatischen Zone sehr viel Sinn macht. Es gibt so ein paar Parks, die an der Windrichtung ausgerichtet sind, sodass der Wind da durchbläst und so weiter. Nichts desto trotz ist das eine sehr exklusive Stadt und ich warte nur darauf, dass diese Stadt fertiggestellt ist und die ganzen Leute, die sich das leisten können, dahin ziehen, was natürlich sehr attraktiv ist. Und die haben dann aber alle zwei, drei Bedienstete und da gibt es dann so das Hausmädchen und die Reinigungsdame und den Taxifahrer, die sich das nicht leisten können, in Master City zu wohnen und wir werden auf jeden Fall neben Master City sozusagen die Non-Master City finden, wo die ganzen anderen leben, die alle überhaupt nicht die Mittel haben, diese ökologischen Infrastrukturen zu bezahlen und das wird sehr interessant werden zu sehen, wie sozusagen die perfekte Stadt und die Support-Stadt, die das so überhaupt erst möglich macht, daneben entsteht und was da die Wechselwirkungen sind und wenn man jetzt, wir kommen immer weiter ab von unserem geschichtlichen Kontext, aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel die Ökobilanz von so einer Stadt ausrechnen möchte, Der muss dann halt dieses Gesamtsystem wieder in Betracht ziehen. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass Master City, wenn man das wirklich auf massbar beschränkt, sagen wir wirklich plus Energie liefert oder null Prozent Arbeitslosigkeit hat oder was auch immer. Aber wenn man eben den Blick etwas aufweitet und zwei Schritte zurückgeht und den Slum daneben, der sicherlich entstehen wird, mit einbezieht, dann sieht das wiederum ganz anders aus. Und das ist eben wiederum das Interessante und das Komplexe an diesem System statt. Dieser ganzheitliche Funktionszusammenhang. Der sich eigentlich erst so in der Zeit dann wirklich beantwortet. Wie ist denn das so bei Brasilia? Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass da jetzt Wäscheleinen unter der Autobahnbrücke hängen, hatte das so halbwegs funktioniert oder ist das noch unklar? Es ist bestimmt nicht noch unklar, aber ich war selbst nicht da und ich würde gerne mal hin, um mir das selber anzugucken. Es ist ganz klar das Mekka der Architekturtouristen, die da ganz vorsichtig schwarz gekleidet durch die Gänge huschen und ihre T-Shirts aufstellen. Und das ist ganz klar in der Fachdiskussion als gescheitert, abgeheftet, als Idealstadt, die eben nicht funktioniert und die Bewohner sind nicht zufrieden und niemand wollte dahin ziehen und so weiter. Was ist Scheitern? Ästhetisch ist es sicherlich ein Erfolg. Weißt du, also ich würde dahin pilgern aus den Gründen, die wir eben verwöhnt haben, aber ich würde nicht dort wohnen wollen. Genau. Und das ist generell vielleicht eine ganz gute Frage. Würde man dort wohnen wollen, da kann man wieder jetzt in der kontemporären Situation auf die zwei verschiedenen Modelle, auf die Hauptmodelle der Stadt, die wir in den letzten Jahrzehnten gesehen haben, zurückkommen. Wir haben zum einen ein Modell der Stadt, was ich jetzt mal die amerikanische Stadt nenne. Das ist jetzt sozusagen die Stadt der Nachmoderne, die wir alle kennen. Das ist der Finanz- oder Business District, ein Zentrum mit Hochhäusern. Das ist eine Stadt, die auf dem Auto basiert, mit der Shopping Mall, wo man einkaufen geht, vielleicht mit dem Einfamilienhaus außerhalb, wo man wohnt, mit den Kindern im Garten. Und das funktioniert so halbwegs. Das ist ein amerikanisches Lebensmodell, was man aber genauso auch in Holland oder England finden kann. Und vor allem sehr stark das Modell ist für neu entstehende Städte in Afrika und in Asien. Und was eben auch geplant ist. Auf der anderen Seite findet man das Modell der Stadt, das aus sich selbst heraus entstanden ist und das dann sehr oft eben zu so islam-ähnlichen Zuständen führt, wenn zu wenig Einfluss genommen wird oder wenn die Leute arm sind. Ein totales Chaos. Man sieht gerade in Südamerika und in Südostasien diese beiden Städte auch direkt nebeneinander existieren, was einem mit der europäischen Perspektive immer ein bisschen in Erstaunen versetzt. Da gibt es so großartige Fotos von so Hochhäusern mit Pools auf einzelnen Terrassen und dann ein Zaun und daneben der Slum. Und wenn wir jetzt argumentieren wollen, welches Bild der Stadt ist das bessere oder in welcher Stadt möchte ich leben, dann kann ich mal sagen, ich will weder in der einen Stadt noch in der anderen Stadt leben. Ich will auf gar keinen Fall isoliert leben, wo ich jedes Mal ein Auto brauche, wenn ich eine Flasche Milch kaufen möchte. Und ich habe gerade in Nairobi eine Zeit lang so gelebt. Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich natürlich auch nicht in der Favela leben. Da wird dann wieder dieses mittelalterliche Bild darauf geschworen. Da kriege ich bestimmt die Flasche Milch direkt um die Ecke, aber ich habe auch kein fließendes Wasser. Also ich bin auch immer sehr skeptisch mit den Romantikern, die dieses Bild zu sehr propagieren. Und das ist auch, wenn man sich die Geschichte anguckt, immer wieder natürlich so ein Pendeln von dem einen Extrem zum anderen, von dem Dreck der industriellen Stadt hin zu der Moderne, wo dann jegliche Lebendigkeit verloren gegangen ist. Und jetzt pendeln wir eben gerade wieder zurück. Unsere Städte sind zugeplant. Jetzt wünschen wir uns so ein bisschen Istanbul hier. Da gibt es dann so ganz viele Tendenzen auch in der Fachdiskussion. Gerade die noch besser organisierten Holländer, wo ich ja viel gearbeitet habe, die gucken gerade ganz stark nach Asien. Wie kriegen wir hier mehr Mess? Wie kriegen wir mehr Leben hier in unserer Stadt? Ja, in Holland ist es ja auch alles ganz furchtbar aufgeräumt und gradlinig und langweilig. Also da stirbt die Kreativität schon in mir, wenn ich das sehe. Wobei es ja durchaus auch andere Ecken gibt in Holland. Du hast von dieses Almere da als Alternative. Ich meine, das ist ja wirklich ganz anders als Amsterdam, während man dann Amsterdam revisiert. Und auch da ist es ja eigentlich eine sehr geplante Stadt. Und auch von so einer Industrialisierung trifft es an der Stelle nicht, sondern aus diesem Handelsding heraus. Die Kanäle etc., die ganzen Lagergebäude etc., überhaupt diese Zugänglichkeit der Stadt mit dem Schiff. Das hat ja diese Stadt enorm geprägt und hat eine Architektur hervorgebracht, die ja auch ganz wunderbar anzuschauen ist. Auch wenn ich mir sicher bin, dass es zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das alles so entstand, da sicherlich auch nicht überall unbedingt toll war, da zu wohnen, sondern erst jetzt, wo da überall sozusagen Lofts reingebaut werden. Trotzdem hast du da eben ein sehr lebendiges Stadtbild im Endergebnis, während jetzt Almere, da bin ich nur durchgefahren, eben so dieses typische holländische Neustadt-Ding, da ist der Name wieder so implementiert, wo man irgendwie bei der dritten Straße schon nicht mehr weiß, ob man nicht in der vierten ist und irgendwie alles immer gleich aussieht. Ja, richtig. Also da sprichst du auch wieder einen wichtigen Punkt der kontemporären Stadt an, das ist die Homogenität, die eben auch jetzt mit vielerlei Initiativen oder vielerlei Ideen versucht wird zu durchbrechen. In Almere ganz klar, das ist eine Stadt, die wiederum sehr geplant ist und auf der anderen Seite genau diese Probleme hat. Verkehr funktioniert fantastisch, die Radwege sind getrennt vom Autoverkehr, man muss nie eine Ampel anhalten, solange man auf den Hauptachsen bleibt, auch als Radfahrer nicht. Es gibt teilweise sogar Brücken, alles fantastisch. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es eben genau wieder diese Reibung nicht, die uns vielleicht manchmal gefällt. Also vielleicht ist es ja für den Holländern Almere undenkbar, in einem Straßencafé direkt an der Hauptstraße zu sitzen. Das kommt einfach nicht vor. Aber genau sieht nämlich ein Großteil von Barcelona aus. Da raufen die Autos in einem vorbei, während man da mit dem Stühlchen gerade so halb auf dem Parkplatz sitzt. Und das gefällt dann irgendwie auch. Also da gibt es wieder verschiedene Modelle. Und ja, andererseits ist Almere die schnellsten wachsende Stadt in Europa im Moment. Das heißt, die Leute ziehen dahin. Zumindest in Holland. Gleichzeitig wurde Almere in einer populären holländischen Radiosendung vor drei, vier Jahren zur hässlichsten Stadt in Holland gewählt. Vom Publikum. Gleichzeitig... Wollen alle hin... .wollen die schnellsten. Total hässlich. Lass uns da hinziehen. Aber es ist eben die Nähe zu Amsterdam wiederum. Es ist eben dann doch ein Idealbild vom Leben, vom modernen Leben, das wir eigentlich wahrscheinlich alle mehr oder weniger haben. Was die Leute dort anzieht und das Bild ist natürlich vor der Nase die lebendige Innenstadt und hinterm Haus den grünen Garten in der Natur. Und das bietet eben Almere so ein bisschen. Man ist eine halbe Stunde im Zentrum von Amsterdam und gleichzeitig ist man irgendwie im Grünen und die Kinder, da braucht man keine Angst haben, wenn die auf der Straße spielen. Auf gewisser Inzicht ist es einfach nur eine extreme Version der Vorstadt, die man ja eigentlich auch hier in Deutschland durchaus findet. Also wenn man jetzt ein bisschen rausfährt aus Berlin, dann hat man natürlich dann auch so die neuen Siedlungen und da wird es dann auch schnell ein bisschen langweilig mit den ganzen eintönigen Einfamilien- Reihenhäusern. Jeder lebt da sozusagen in einem identischen Haus wie sein Nachbar, was ja auch, wo ich auch so mental ein bisschen aussteige. Aber es gibt interessanterweise schon in vielen Kulturen da wirklich noch einen Run da drauf. Also ich war auch gerade in Kolumbien, Bogota, auch so eine Stadt, die so ihre Probleme hat mit ihren Wachstumsschmerzen und die auch, sagen wir mal, stadtplanerisch das eine oder andere Grundproblem hat, vor allem mit dem Verkehr. Also Kolumbien zum Beispiel ist ein Land, was die unfassbare Fehlentscheidung gehabt hat, vor 30 Jahren einfach alle Züge abzuschaffen, einfach keine Züge. Und jetzt haben sie natürlich ein unglaubliches Verkehrstransport- Problem, weil sich da einfach nur die Lastwagenlobby durchgesetzt hat, macht man alles mit Lastwagen, mit den entsprechenden Auswirkungen auf Straßenbeschaffenheit, Luftverschmutzung, Lärm etc., Oder dass alle Schulen, alle guten Schulen, außerhalb gebaut wurden und die Leute dann aber trotzdem in der Stadt wohnen und jeden Tag diese Stadt unter einen Verkehrs- Stress gestellt wird, nur um diese Schüler dorthin zu bringen oder bzw. den Stress dann eigentlich auf die Schüler ablädt, weil die genau diesen einen Schulbus, der sie dann eine Stunde lang durch diese Gegend fährt, kriegen müssen, um überhaupt an der Schule teilnehmen zu können. Naja, dann war ich halt ein bisschen draußen, quasi auf der anderen Seite der Bergkette, die da Bogota begibt und dann hast du dann wieder eben so die normale, kleinere Stadt und auch dort neue Siedlungen, alles homogen, alles gleich, auch so gated, community, gut beschützt halbwegs, ja, mit so ein bisschen Agora, ja, wir haben da sozusagen so unseren eigenen gemeinsamen Platz mit dem Schwimmbad und da können wir uns treffen und unsere langweiligen Halloween-Partys feiern, weil man kriegte da Beklemmung, also ich kriegte da einfach totale Beklemmung. Und die eigentliche Frage, die mich die ganze Zeit schon beschäftigt ist, gibt es denn überhaupt Städte, die gut funktionieren? Gibt es denn überhaupt Beispiele für Stadt, naja, vielleicht gar nicht mal erst mal Stadtplanung? Gibt es überhaupt erst mal ein Beispiel für eine Stadt, wo man sich sagt, holla, hier haben wir irgendwie die richtige Mischung aus der Verquickung von Industrie und Wohnen und von Arbeit und Leben und von, es ist irgendwie grün genug, aber es ist auch urban genug und wir haben genug Cafés und Variants auch in der Durchmischung von Arm und Reich etc., wo man hin zeigt und sagt, naja, da hat sich jetzt über einen Zeitraum vielleicht von 100, 200 Jahren etwas herausgebildet, warum nehmen wir nicht einfach diese Durchmischung hier, messen die, versuchen die irgendwie auf so einen Algorithmus zu bringen und skalieren das dann mal hoch und bauen mal so einen Stadtteil komplett neu? Oder ist das unrealistisch? Du hast einige Fragen angesprochen, also wir haben jetzt Verkehr als eins der Hauptprobleme in der modernen Stadt. Dann hast du über gated communities gesprochen, da geht es ganz klar um so ein Sicherheitsbedürfnis der Menschen und um Homogenität und dann letztlich die Frage, was gibt es für gut funktionierende Städte, wo wollen die Leute hin oder was für Modelle könnte man dann kopieren zum Beispiel, was natürlich auch versucht wird. Es gibt interessante Projekte in China, wo dann wirklich Amsterdam eins zu eins nachgebaut wird. Also das passiert wirklich auch ganz gedankenfrei in einem ganz anderen Klima oder ohne Wasser oder oder so, weißt du. Aber Amsterdam ohne Wasser ist gut. Das Wasser muss erstmal hergekarrt werden. Das ist so wie Rio nachbauen ohne Strand. Solche Sachen. Verkehr ist auf jeden Fall eins der Hauptprobleme. Da gibt es natürlich zum einen ganz viele innovative technische Lösungen, wenn wir jetzt so über Reduzieren von Emissionen und so weiter reden und auch wenn wir über das Energieproblem nachdenken. Aber für den Stadtplaner ist natürlich eher interessant, was die Straße bedeutet und was es da für verschiedene Tendenzen gab. Wir kennen alle, wir sehen das auch hier in Berlin, die grandiosen Stadtautobahn-Projekte, die so in den 60er, 70ern aufgekommen sind und die dann aus heutiger Perspektive sich oft Gott sei Dank nicht durchsetzen konnten. Wir haben im Südwesten der Stadt so einige Autobahnstücke, die ins Nichts führen und einfach nicht weitergebeult wurden. Und da hat der Zweig des Verkehrsingenieurwesens auch einige interessante Entdeckungen gemacht in jüngerer Zeit. Eine neue Faustregel ist zum Beispiel, dass sich das Verkehrsproblem durch neue Straßen nicht lösen lässt. Weil neue Straßen eigentlich immer so eine Verhaltensveränderung bei den Menschen hervorbringen, dass die Straße sofort wieder ausgelastet wird. Also es wird so viel angenehmer, wieder mit dem Auto zu fahren, dass die Straße wieder voll ist. Und die Leute hören erst auf, das Auto zu benutzen, wenn es wieder den nächsten Verkehrsstau gibt. Das heißt, diese eigentlich logische Idee, wir haben ein Verkehrsproblem, wir brauchen zwei mehr Spuren, scheitert immer wieder. Also es muss auf jeden Fall andere Denkansätze geben und das Verkehrsproblem zu lösen. Und das kann alles Mögliche sein, das kann umsteigen auf öffentlichen Nahverkehr sein und den öffentlichen Nahverkehr sehr attraktiv machen. Das sind oft in den Metropolen von heute ganz einfach Gesetze. Da sind ganz vorne dabei zum Beispiel Singapur, die so eine automatische Maut haben. In Singapur machen sie es einfach teurer, mit den Privatwagen zu fahren, als mit dem öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Ganz einfach, du zahlst in Singapur 6 Euro, wenn du in die Stadt reinfährst am Morgen, noch mal 6 Euro, wenn du rausfährst. Du musst auch gar keine Karte kaufen, dein Auto wird automatisch erfasst von Kameras und du merkst davon gar nichts, es geht einfach vom Konto runter. Oder zum Beispiel in Peking gibt es so ein System, dass an geraden Monatstagen nur Leute mit geradem, mit gerader Nummer auf den Nummerschild fahren dürfen und an ungeraden Tagen auch. Das führt dann natürlich dazu, dass die Reichenfamilien zwei Autos haben, eins mit gerader Nummer und eins mit ungerader Nummer. Da gibt es auch wieder interessante Folgen-Effekte. Und da sind die Schlagwörter heutzutage Mikromobilität oder auch integrierte Mobilität, dass man versucht, Verkehrssysteme mit öffentlichem Verkehr zu schaffen, die auf verschiedenen Ebenen funktionieren. Also da geht es vor allem um diese Transitionspunkte, dass es halt extrem praktisch und einfach wird, von der Bahn auf die Straßenbahn, aufs Fahrrad, aufs Leihauto ins Taxi umzusteigen. Das ist halt sozusagen möglichst reibungslos funktioniert. Also hier so Park-and-Ride-Konzepte, Car-Sharing, hier in Berlin eine ganze Menge davon. Oder auch, dass du mit einem Ticket am besten das Leihfahrrad von der Bahn dir nehmen kannst und gleichzeitig damit auch Zug fahren kannst. Das ist alles so integriert. Dahin geht so das Denken zurzeit. Und man muss auch sagen, dass die Zeit der großen Verkehrsprojekte jetzt eher so im westlichen Kontext vorbei ist. Es wird halt immer schwieriger, Riesenprojekte durchzusetzen, was einfach an unseren sehr positiven, natürlich demokratischen Strukturen liegt. Also, Flughafen bauen zum Beispiel. Okay, da stecken noch ganz andere Probleme dahinter. Aber ja. Also überhaupt erst mal zu planen, den Ort zu finden etc. Richtig. Wider Sprüche, Ansprüche. Genau. Also überleg mal heutzutage hier in Berlin den Hausmann machen zu wollen und eine neue Schneise von Nord nach Süd in die Stadt rein zu schlagen, damit wir da eine neue Axt haben. Das geht nicht mehr. Du musst mit jedem Eigentümer verhandeln. Jeder hat irgendwelche Rechte, das ist nicht mehr zu machen, weil das eben dieser, diesen Diktator sozusagen einfach nicht mehr gibt. Und deswegen geht es jetzt natürlich vielmehr um Ansätze, die chirurgischer sind, die nicht so zentrale Lösungsansätze haben, sondern eher versuchen das System zu verändern. Also dass dann eben so ein Fahrrad-Leihsystem viel smarter, als jetzt zu versuchen, eben die nächste Startautobahn. Es funktioniert besser, es ist oft billiger und das ist natürlich dann auch nachhaltiger gedacht. Zu den Einfamilien-Haus, oder sagen wir zu den gated communities, das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem. Wir haben ja am Anfang festgestellt, dass wir uns so die kreative Stadt so vorstellen, die dann auch ökonomische, positive Effekte nach sich zieht, so vorstellen, dass da verschiedene Lifestyles aufeinandertreffen und daraus entsteht irgendwie das Neue, so dieser Mix. Und die gated community ist ja genau das Gegenteil. Es ist eine äußerst homogene Gruppe von Menschen, die sich sicher fühlt, dass sie auch unter dasselbe leisten können, mit einem ähnlichen Einkommen, mit einer ähnlichen Hautfarbe, mit einem ähnlichen sozialen Hintergrund. Und die leben dann hinter der Mauer und vorne kontrolliert einer, ob du dann auch dazugehörst oder nicht oder ob du eingeladen bist. Und statt räumlich kannst du dann da auch nicht einfach die Abkürzung durchnehmen, wenn du da jeden Tag zur Arbeit musst. Du musst halt außen rumlaufen. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem. Auf der anderen Seite liegt es, trotz all unserem idealistischen Denken über diese lebendige Stadt, vielleicht sind wir auch besonders, weil wir nach Berlin gezogen sind oder eben in einer Großstadt leben, einfach so in so einer Wohnung, fühlen sich Menschen doch am wohlsten unter seinesgleichen. Also es gibt eine sehr wenige, die wirklich sagen, ja, ich will in der Gegend wohnen, wo auch ganz viele alte Leute oder ganz viel Arme oder ganz viel Reiche, wenn ich selber arm bin. Es gibt immer ganz klar so Tendenzen, dass die Leute unter seinesgleichen, dass die sich so gruppieren. Sieht man ja auch hier in Prenzlauer Berg. Das ist einfach so eine automatische Tendenz. Und dazu kommt noch, und das ist natürlich auch sehr kontextbezogen, dieses Bedürfnis nach Sicherheit, was so eine große Rolle spielt. Und da gibt es auch wieder verschiedene Ansätze. Natürlich ist Sicherheit viel wichtiger in Sao Paulo als Sicherheit ist in Berlin. Deswegen gibt es dort auch mehr gated communities. Es gibt einfach viel mehr bewaffnete Überfälle und viel größeres Gefälle von Arm und Reich. Das ist letztlich das eigentliche Problem. Also wenn man es an der Wurzel packen wollte, müsste man natürlich wieder gesellschaftliche Veränderungen hervorrufen und die Kluft zwischen Reich und Arm überbrücken. Und dann bräuchte es auch weniger Mauern. Aber das ist ja alles nicht so einfach. Wenn man jetzt wieder als Stadtplaner argumentiert, gibt es eben auch vielfältige Konzepte. Man kann halt eine Mauer bauen und eine Sicherheitskamera installieren oder man kann, dafür gibt es auch Beispiele, die Stadt so strukturieren, dass eben Leute an Straßen wohnen und sich für ihre Straße verantwortlich fühlen. Da gibt es vielerlei Beispiele. Zum Beispiel sind in Vancouver neue Stadtteile so geplant worden. Da gab es große Sicherheitsbedenken für zentrale Innenstadtbereiche, die nachts eben ausgestorben sind und dann gab es dort Überfälle oder Vergewaltigungen und so weiter. Deswegen haben die angefangen, in den ersten zwei Geschossen der Büro- und Wohnhochhäuser sozusagen entlang der Straße in dem Sockel kleine Geschäfte anzusiedeln oder auch sogar Sozialwohnungen von Leuten, die dort wohnen, mit Tür direkt zur Straße raus, die sozusagen das Wohnzimmerfenster auf die Straße raus haben. Und plötzlich waren die Leute nicht nur darum besorgt, dass sich niemand so in der Tüte Müll einfach vor das Haus stellt, weil die wohnen ja da, wenn es einfach ein Business District ist, dann juckt es niemand, außer es kommt halt die Firma wieder durch und macht es sauber. Sondern gleichzeitig gab es dann auch wieder so eine softe, so eine weiche Nachbarschaftskontrolle. Jetzt nicht die Patrouille, die da durchläuft, aber einfach Leute, die aus ihrem Fenster rausgucken und sofort geht die Gewalt runter. Also da gibt es sozusagen so weiche Ansätze, wo man eigentlich auch Sicherheit mit erzeugen kann. Ja, das merkt man schon so im Kleinen, wenn man so Supermärkten vorbeigeht, die für eine tolle Idee finden, bis auf ihren Eingang irgendwie alles zuzukleistern und keine Fenster zu haben und so weiter. Und sofort geht da irgendwie so ein kalter Schauer über den Rücken. Das ist interessant, ja. Genau das. Und das kann man sich natürlich auch überlegen, wenn man jetzt so an Revitalisierung von so homogenen Stadtvierteln aus den 60ern, 70ern denkt. Wie schafft man das? Also, weißt du, so Wohnviertel, die so am Rande des sozialen Absturzes sind und so weiter. Und da muss man dann eben auch wieder so eine Durchmischung hineinbringen und da kann man gucken, dass man eben auch diese Erdgeschosszone mobilisiert. Zum Beispiel haben wir gerade mit unserem Büro für die Holländer eine Studie gemacht, wie man eben die zu homogenen Straßen wieder reaktivieren kann. Da gab es eben auch gerade in den Außenbezirken von Amsterdam so eine Autobahn, eine Startautobahn, die durch ein Wohngebiet durchgeht und wo es genau das Problem gibt, dass in den Unterführungen unter dieser Autobahndurchsicht die Leute äußerst unwohl fühlen. Die wollen diese Autobahn einfach nicht kreuzen, weil es dort natürlich total stark windet. Es gibt so ein paar Neonröhre an der Unterseite der Autobahn und ansonsten Betonpfeiler und da läuft man vor allem als Frau einfach nachts nicht durch. Das Problem lässt sich ganz einfach lösen, wenn man dort gerade solche Funktionen ansiedelt, die eigentlich keine Fenster brauchen. Also an beiden Seiten sagen wir ein Wellness-Spa und auf der anderen Seite einen Supermarkt mit Fassade machen würde oder ein paar kleine Geschäfte, dann wäre da sofort was los oder für mich ist eine Bar. Dann wäre da sofort statt einem Wald aus Betonsäulen und 60 Metern Niemandsland ein paar kleine Geschäfte, ein paar kleine Bar, Leute, die ein- und ausgehen und plötzlich wäre das Problem beseitigt. Weil man eine soziale Kontrolle installiert. Richtig. Also man muss gar nicht immer wirklich die die Struktur verändern oder die Autobahn muss weg oder man kann sozusagen auch mit so kleinen Eingriffen oft sehr starke Veränderungen erzeugen. Und das ist eigentlich schon zu dem dritten Aspekt, den du angesprochen hast. Was sind denn die gut funktionierenden Städte? Und das sind eben zumindest heutzutage oft Städte, die dem ähneln. Also wenn man sich die Indizes anguckt, es gibt jedes Jahr eine Vielzahl von Instituten und Zeitschriften, die so die Lebensqualität missen. Genau, die so die zehn Städte mit der höchsten Lebensqualität, the top ten most livable cities in the world auflisten. Da gibt es das Monocle-Magazin, das so eine Liste hat. Da gibt es das Mercer Institute, das auch so eine Liste hat. Und da kommt immer wieder vor Zürich. Manchmal höre man München, ganz oft Kopenhagen, Portland, Vancouver, Melbourne, um es jetzt mal ein bisschen global aufzuweiten. Vielleicht Singapur. Und das sind oft Städte, die, das hängt natürlich davon ab, welche Indikatoren diese einzelnen Listen benutzen, aber das sind oft Städte, die durchgrün sind, wo es eine gewisse Sicherheit gibt, wo es eine gewisse Mischung gibt, wo es eine gewisse Anzahl an kulturellen Angeboten gibt, wo es ein öffentliches, gut funktionierendes öffentliches Nahverkehrssystem gibt. Und diese Modelle versucht man zurzeit zu... Das sind aber auch sehr reiche Städte. Also ich kenne jetzt nicht alle, aber Kopenhagen und Zürich sind ja auch nicht gerade dafür bekannt, besonders billig zu sein. Das ist das ist auf jeden Fall ein Haken dieser Listen, dass zum einen die Städte zwar oft sehr nett sind, aber wieder nur für eine bestimmte Gruppe und zum anderen ich ganz ehrlich oft denke, ja, sehr ganz nett, aber ich wollte da gar nicht wohnen. Ja, ich auch nie. Also ich kenne jetzt Wenkowar und Melber nicht, aber... Naja, aber wenn man jetzt Zürich, Kopenhagen, München also andenkt, das ist mir einfach dann irgendwie zu langweilig, weil uns fehlt da vielleicht genau diese Reibung oder ein bisschen so der Dreck oder wieder das Unerwartete, was sich halt in diesen Listen wieder schlecht einfangen lässt. Aber da sind wir bestimmt auch wiederum jetzt ein Menschenschlag, der auch nicht so mainstream ist. Na gut, aber es gibt sicherlich etwas, was nicht so ohne Weiteres messbar ist, aber was man vielleicht dann trotzdem mal, wenn auch nicht quantifizieren, doch zumindest qualifizieren möchte. Deswegen frage ich mich, hast du da eine persönliche Meinung, hast du eine persönliche Erfahrung, hast du mal eine Stadt erlebt, du kannst Berlin ja auch gerne mit einschließen, die für dich den Ausgleich zwischen den wesentlichen Parametern, also allgemeine Durchmischungen, Kreativität, Ökologie, Verkehr in einem sowohl praktischen als auch erträglichen Maße, wo da eine gute Balance ist, wo du sagen würdest, das ist jetzt auch stadtpladerisch mal etwas, wo man vielleicht genauer hinschauen sollte. Ja, sicherlich. Also ich kann da natürlich wirklich nur die Städte heranziehen, in denen ich selber gelebt habe oder für längere Zeit Besuch da und deswegen ist es ganz klar nicht repräsentativ, sondern eine persönliche Erfahrung. War jetzt auch genauso gefragt. Aber die Städte, die bei mir jetzt ganz hoch rangieren, sind auf jeden Fall Barcelona, wo ich gut anderthalb Jahre gelebt habe und eben auch Berlin. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich wieder hier bin. Dann gibt es so ein paar Städte im Randbereich. Ich zähle mal die anderen auf. Ich bin zurzeit sehr fasziniert von Moskau, wo wir ein paar Projekte bearbeiten, aber ich wollte dort nicht leben. Im Moment denke ich noch, ich würde da gerne mal leben, aber wahrscheinlich würde ich mir das nach einem Monat anders überlegen. Nach einem Monat vor Ort? Das sagen wir alle Moskowiten. Ja, ja, das sagst du jetzt, aber nur, weil du nicht hier bist. Auf die Details können wir gleich eingehen. Wieso das so ist. Ich habe jetzt gerade ein halbes Jahr in Nairobi gelebt, was überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, obwohl ich dort für viele vielleicht den Traum des Neokolonialisten gelebt habe, mit Villa und riesigem Garten und Hausangestellten, aber es ging trotzdem überhaupt gar nicht. Und ja, dann habe ich noch in Rotterdam gelebt und vielleicht noch in Hamburg in der Zeit und so. Und was man jetzt vielleicht generell sagen kann, fangen wir mal an mit Nairobi, weil ich gerade gesagt habe, es geht gar nicht. Nairobi ist eine Stadt, die sich komplett auf das Auto verlässt, plus ein Sicherheitsproblem hat. Und noch dazu, der Autoverkehr nicht funktioniert, weil es eine Stadt ist, die in einem hügeligen Gebiet ist und es deswegen kein richtiges Straßennetz geben kann, sondern immer nur so schlaufen, wo man endlos fährt. Das führt dazu, dass man letztlich in seiner zugegebenermaßen wunderbaren Villa sitzt und dann eben seinen Fahrer oder ein Taxi ruft, nur um mal ins Restaurant zu gehen oder nur mal einzukaufen. Und dafür steht man dann eine halbe oder eine Stunde im Stau und fährt dann irgendwann wieder zurück. Also ohne Auto geht das gar nicht. Und es gibt dann eben auch keine Öffentlichkeit. Weil selbst an den Ort, wo man sich trifft, sagen wir, an eine nette Bar oder ein Restaurant, wird man natürlich am Eingang erstmal auf Waffen durchsucht und kann dann eintreten. Und dann findet dann so eine selektierte, simulierte Öffentlichkeit im Innenhof statt. Eben nicht auf der Straße. Es gibt natürlich noch, natürlich ist es wichtig zu sagen, dass er natürlich als weißer Alien dort war. Und natürlich gibt es noch eine ganz andere Öffentlichkeit in der Innenstadt bei Nacht, wo sich die eigentlichen Kenianer locker auch mal flanieren können, je nachdem, ob gerade eine Wahl stattfindet oder nicht. Und das konnte ich halt nicht machen. Ich bin ein, zwei Mal nachts in die Stadt spaziert und dann habe ich Leute, die ich nicht kannte, auf der Straße angesprochen und mir gesagt, bist du verrückt, hier einfach so lang zu laufen? Das ist zu gefährlich. Los, steig ins Auto. Das war eine gut gemeinte Warnung. Genau. Und das hat für mich nicht funktioniert. Und das ist auch dann so eine typische Stadt mit Central Business Trick. Und eben dann hast du da deine geschützte Welt in der Villa mit zwei bewaffneten Bächtern am Zaun, die Tag und Nacht auf dich aufpassen. Klingt super. Dann hat man natürlich die Megastädte von heute. Moskau hat zurzeit geschätzte 18 Millionen Einwohner. Das ist sechsmal Berlin. Berlin mit Umland. Und natürlich passieren da die Dinge, die uns jetzt vielleicht auch in Berlin gereizt haben, in noch größerem Ausmaß. Es kann jederzeit alles passieren. Es ist Tag und Nacht Leben. Man findet alle möglichen Menschen und alles mögliche Essen und alle möglichen Styles von Clubs, Bars und Restaurants, alle möglichen Angebote. Aber gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich auch so ein Limit, wo eine Stadt anstrengend wird. Umso größer die Stadt, umso weiter sind die Wege, umso voller ist es überall, umso härter ist auch der Konkurrenzkampf, gerade wenn es eine Stadt ist, wo es eben viele Menschen gibt, die ökonomisch kämpfen, um überleben zu können. Und deswegen finde ich es sehr aufregend. Aber letztlich bin ich da vielleicht dann auch fast schon wieder so spießig, zu sagen, dass mir jetzt so die Städte in Europa mit so zwei, drei Millionen Einwohnern, mit einem gewissen kulturellen Angebot, die geschichtlich gewachsen sind, mit einer gewissen Dichte und Durchmischung, wo ich mich immer im Viertel bewegen kann, zu Fuß und wiedererkannt werde. Es ist ja sehr nett, wenn man der Bäcker dann sagt, ah ja, wie immer ein Croissant. Dass man so etwas haben kann und trotzdem noch das kulturelle Angebot im Hintergrund, wo man ruhig mal auch beklaut werden kann. Aber dafür hat man eben auch Underground-Theater. Das ist ja so eine Balance. Und das ist so die Stadt, die ich mag, weißt du? Ich will nicht in der Stadt leben, wo ich umgebracht werden kann, wenn ich an der Ampel stehen bleibe, wie in Nairobi oder vielleicht Sao Paulo in der falschen Ecke. Auch wenn es dann total coole Partys gibt. Das ist mir vielleicht zu viel. Und ich will auf gar keinen Fall selber komplett geschützt im Door auf wo alles kontrolliert ist oder in der gated Community leben. Das ist ja irgendwie so ein Mittelweg, der jetzt für mich funktioniert. Kann ich gut nachvollziehen, die Kriterien. Ich glaube, da sind wir auch so ein bisschen auf derselben Welle. Also wir haben ja jetzt viel über Städte geredet und auch ansatzweise schon so ein bisschen, was so die Herausforderungen generell sind für Städte und natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch für die Stadtplanung. Jetzt mal wirklich so auf den Beruf des Stadtplaners uns mehr konzentrieren und sagen, okay, jetzt gibt es da konkrete Projekte und Herausforderungen. Du hast ja an einigen auch teilgenommen. Was ist denn das meistens? Ist es meistens mit, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie mal einen Stadtteil wieder auf Vordermann bringen, damit er wieder funktioniert oder wir bauen irgendwie aus oder was sind so die Herausforderungen, die so für den Stadtplaner eigentlich, man kann wahrscheinlich schwer generalisieren, aber vielleicht kannst du das mal so ein bisschen kategorisieren, was für Tätigkeiten da jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich anstehen. Ja, man kann das ganz klar kategorisieren. Das kommt zum ersten auf die Weltregion an, in der man arbeitet. Dann stellen sich natürlich verschiedene Fragen und Themen und zweitens funktioniert das auf verschiedenen Maßstäben. Also in Europa geht es ganz klar vor allem um Stadtumbau, um Revitalisierung, vor allem um den Umgang mit dem Erbe der modernen Stadt der 60er und 70er Jahre. Dann gibt es das ganz große Thema im europäischen Kontext, bis hin auch nach Russland der schrumpfenden Städte, dass es eben Abwanderung gibt. Wie kann man Städte, wo die Bevölkerung zurückgeht, rückbauen? Wie kann man die trotzdem lebendig halten? Da stellen sich so Fragen wie Lebensversorge. Wie kann man die noch versorgen? Wie kann man versorgen, dass die Kinder noch zur Schule kommen, wenn sich die Schule vielleicht gar nicht mehr halten kann, weil die Bevölkerung nicht da ist? Das ist ja hier im Osten ein krasses Problem, immer noch. Dass die Städte Ostdeutschlands im Vergleich zu vor 20 Jahren, weiß nicht, einen guten Teil ihrer Bevölkerung verloren haben, nicht 20 Prozent. Und an einem bestimmten Punkt bricht dann alles so ein bisschen weg, weil es zu teuer wird, die Infrastruktur zu erhalten. Die Infrastruktur funktioniert nicht und dann fühlt man sich auch plötzlich nicht mehr wohl. Dann gibt es wieder so soziale Probleme. Zum Beispiel, das kannst du dir ja gut vorstellen, wenn man so eine Platte hat im Osten, die eigentlich mal gedacht war, sagen wir, für 80 Wohneinheiten. Und wenn dann da nur noch zwölf Familien drin leben, dann wird das halt so ein bisschen furchteinflößend, durch die leeren Flure zu tappen. Und dann frieren eben auch die Leitungen ein und so, wenn dann nicht genügend Wasser durchfließt. Und dann, es ist natürlich besser, das Ding abzureißen. Oder, wenn es denn geht, die obersten sechs Stockwerke abzureißen. Und dann leben halt alle nur noch in den ersten zwei Stockwerken. Und dann ist wieder alles voll. Das kennt man ja auch, diesen Effekt. Dann fühlt es sich wieder an, als ob es in Ordnung wäre. Wogegen sich, ja, und die Auftraggeber, das kann man vielleicht an der Stelle noch sagen, sind dann entweder die Städte selbst, die Stadtverwaltung, wobei in Deutschland die Stadtverwaltung viele selber tun. Das ist in Holland wieder ganz anders. Die nehmen dann eher die Dienste des Privatsektors, eben also Planungsbüros, in Anspruch. Oder es sind dann eben einzelne Entwickler, Developer, die dann einzelne Stadtteile entwickeln. Aber das kommt hier mit diesen Rückbauprojekten auch weniger vor. Das findet man dann eher in den Kontexten von Ländern, die gerade eher im Wachstum begriffen sind. Und das ist eben das, was man jetzt sieht, vor allem akut in den sogenannten BRICS-Ländern, Brasilien, Russland, China, Indien. Deswegen BRIC, wegen dieser Buchstaben. Und die halt gerade boomen. Und da wachsen die Städte sehr schnell. Und da gibt es dann eben eher das Problem, dass wirklich groß gedacht werden muss. Wie hier eben im Europa des 19. Jahrhunderts. Und dann plötzlich im Basel oder in Berlin mit einem Plan, die Fläche der Stadt verfünffacht wurde. Und das war gar kein Problem. Das ist im Moment in Europa undenkbar. Solche Projekte gibt es nicht. Und da geht es dann fast wieder darum, dass man groß denken muss, woran manchmal auch dann die europäischen Plane wieder scheitern. Weil sie dann, also was ich auch selber in der TU gelernt habe, natürlich in dem Kontext, hier sind so die kleinen chirurgischen Eingriffe, hier machen wir keinen Platz, hier bauen wir ein Stockwerk zurück. Und dann funktioniert das Viertel wieder. Wenn ich jetzt nach, sagen wir, nach Südamerika gehe und die mir ihre Probleme schildern, dass sie irgendwie 50.000 Wohnungen in den nächsten fünf Jahren bauen müssen, ich sage ja, hier könnte man ein Stockwerk draufsetzen und hier gibt es noch eine Lücke, dann führt das zu nichts. Da muss man dann doch wieder eben groß denken, aber natürlich nicht dumm sein, nicht wieder die Fehler der modernen wiederholen, nicht so das ja vielleicht doch verlockende Ding durchzuziehen. Ich bin jetzt der geniale Masterplanner und ich mache jetzt die idealere Tortenstadt und drücke dir meinen Stempel auf und mit einer Signatur auch noch auf Google zu erkennen, irgendwie in dem Mausblock nachgebaut. Nein, da muss man eben auch wieder versuchen, das, was uns gefällt, die in einer durchmischten Stadt zu lernen und das eben vor allem nicht nur in einem Plan, sondern auch in Prozesse umzusetzen, dass das nach und nach passieren kann, dass es eben diese Flexibilität gibt. Und da sind dann die Auftraggeber auch entweder die Städte, aber oft auch Developer, also Entwickler, die Städte eher, wenn es so um gesamtstädtliche Strategien und Konzepte gibt und Developer dann eher, wenn es so um 60, 70 Hektar große einzelne Stadtteile geht, die irgendwie neu geplant werden. Das war so die grobe Kategorisierung der einzelnen Aufgaben, die sie stellen. Von den Maßstäben her gibt es da auch noch was zu sagen, denke ich. Es geht eben los bei so einem gesamtstädtischen Maßstab, wo man wirklich auf die gesamte Stadt plus, da ist die Landschaft außen rum, die Region anguckt und versucht das Beziehungsnetz zu verstehen und dann eben zu entscheiden, wie sollte sich die Stadt eigentlich entwickeln. Und da ist auf der ersten Schritt auch gar kein Plan, also dass man gar nicht festlegt, wo ist die Straße oder wo kommt die Stadterwaltung hin. Da geht es oft auch darum, so erstmal einen Diskussionsprozess zu initiieren mit den Verantwortlichen der Stadt, aber auch der Bewohner. Wie sieht die Stadt überhaupt aus? Was will Berlin in 20 Jahren sein? Oder das ist vielleicht auch eine Frage, die hier in Berlin zu wenig gestellt wird. Oder wir haben das jetzt selber für Aleppo gemacht. Oder ich diskutiere das auch oft mit vielen afrikanischen Stadtverwaltungen. Wie sich die Städte eben entwickeln. Und da muss man erst einmal herausfinden, soll das ein Verkehrsknotenpunkt sein? Wollt ihr darauf setzen, auch mit der Wirtschaft? Oder wollt ihr Touristen-Stadt werden? Oder wollt ihr einfach eure industrielle Produktion voranbringen? Und das sind natürlich alles Ideen, die sich meistens alle alles wollen. Aber vielleicht ist die Idee, Verkehrsknotenpunkt zu werden, ja nicht kompatibel mit der Idee, Touristen-Attraktionen oder Touristen-Ziel zu werden, das geht da nicht. Da sieht der Hafen vielleicht anders aus. Ja, ich habe eben von den Bricks-Ländern geredet, wo jetzt gerade diese Entwicklung stattfindet. Und global betrachtet wird dann letztlich Afrika die nächste Weltregion sein, wo ein rapides Wachstum stattfinden wird. In Bevölkerung schon jetzt. Und das ist auch abzusehen, das ist wirtschaftlich so in 20, 30 Jahren, der globale Fokus sich daneben auf Afrika richtet. Also Europa ist jetzt sozusagen mehr oder weniger im Stillstand oder im Schrumpfen. Asien ist sehr stark gewachsen gerade. Jetzt gibt es diese Brick-Region mit Südamerika, Indien, Indien wird sich sehr stark entwickeln. Und eigentlich geht man davon aus, dass dann Afrika ein nächstes Ort ist, weil es nicht der einzige ist, bei dem es noch nie so in dem Maße stattgefunden hat. Mit der Ausnahme einziger partieller Regionen. Wobei es ja auch da, wo Geld ist, nicht unbedingt jetzt besonders gut läuft. Wenn man sich die Situation anschaut, da Nigeria, Lagos etc., das sind ja auch teilweise katastrophale Regionen, gerade in ökologischer Hinsicht, weil da eben einfach nicht drüber nachgedacht wird. Ich frage mich jetzt, wenn du da am Anfang sagst, so ja, hier, neues Projekt, ich fange jetzt mal an mit Stadtplanung, jetzt mache ich da mal einen Stadtteil in Moskau, wie übertragbar eigentlich jetzt das ganze Business ist, weil wenn man da irgendwie in Holland sitzt und dann soll man dann irgendwie für eine Kultur, die man gar nicht kennt, da Lösungen finden für das tägliche Zusammenleben, ist das nicht ein bisschen knifflig? Muss man da nicht erst mal lernen, wie der Russe denkt? Ja, und der Russe denkt anders, ich sag dir das. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, ich hab keine Ahnung wie. Also zum einen, es gibt viele Antworten auf die Frage. Zum einen kann man sagen, dass man ja oft als ausländischer Experte eingeladen wurde in diese Länder mit einem guten Grund, nämlich dass die lokalen Verantwortlichen genau das wollten, deine ausländische Perspektive. Und eben gar nicht nur den Spezialisten vor Ort, der sich genau auskennt wollten, sondern sie wollten ja gerade eine finnische, etwas andere Idee, einen neuen Blickwinkel. Und ich habe da auch oft gerade in heiklen politischen Verhältnissen, also wie gesagt, ja du weißt, ich habe in Syrien gearbeitet, ich arbeite im Irak, ich werde Ende des Monats nach Bagdad fliegen. Das wird bestimmt auch spannend. Da reicht es auch oft schon aus, wirklich der Externe zu sein, weil du dadurch Dinge ansprechen kannst, die sich einfach keiner von den Lokalen traut. Das ist offensichtlich. Da könntest auch du hin, als in der Rolle des Stadtplaners. Weil du dann einfach der Einzige, der sagen kann, ja, hört mal, braucht ihr überhaupt so viel neue Fläche für eure Stadterweiterung? Und dann sind alle plötzlich ganz erleichtert, weil natürlich alle schon wussten, dass es da einfach nur um Landspekulation geht und dass da ein paar Typen sehr reich werden, dadurch, dass die Flächen von Landwirtschaft zu Baugebiet umgewickelt sind. Und endlich hat es einer gesagt. Also das ist oft schon eine Rolle, die man ganz gut erfüllt, einfach nur dadurch, dass man von außen kommt. Okay. Dann mit den Ideen und Modellen, die man mitbringt. Ja, das ist dann oft für uns fast schon selbstverständlich, wenn man so sagt, man mag die durchmischte, lebendige Stadt. Ja, das kennen wir, da leben wir drin. Aber je nachdem, wie entwickelt die Gegenden sind, wo man hinkommt, ist das dann doch etwas Neues. Also natürlich, wenn ich nach China fliege, dann kennen die sich komplett aus, auch in Südamerika, und haben einen Überblick über die interessanten Projekte, und die Städte mit hoher Lebensqualität, und haben die auch schon bereist. Aber es ist oft ganz anders, wenn ich mit afrikanischen Stadtplanungsabteilungen spreche, für die das was ganz Neues ist, dass man vielleicht auch eine Werkstatt im gleichen Haus, wo auch Leute wohnen hat. Oder da ist schon das oft eine schwierige Transition, überhaupt einen Gesellschaftswandel zu durchlaufen, dass die Leute nicht mehr in eigenen Garten haben, und im Erdgeschoss wohnen, und plötzlich in einem Wohnhaus im dritten Stock. Das ist ein großer Schritt. Und damit kämpfen gerade viele Städte in Afrika, dass sie zwar Millionen haben und eine höhere Dichte brauchen, weil sie sich nicht endlos wie so ein Pfannkuchen ins Land entwickeln können, mit all den Nachteilen, den weiten Entfernungen. Und vor allem der teuren Infrastruktur. Es ist natürlich viel teurer, eine Wasserleitung zu legen, wo alle 50 Meter Einhaus angeschlossen wird, mit fünf Leuten drin, statt alle 10 Meter ein Haus mit 50. Die Stadt kann das gar nicht bezahlen. Und kommt auch durch die Grundsteuer das nie wieder rein. Und deswegen braucht es die Dichte. Auf der anderen Seite muss es da eben so einen gesellschaftlichen Wandel geben, dass es akzeptabel ist, nicht das eine Land zu besetzen. Oder dass es plötzlich akzeptabel ist, dass man wirklich auf den Supermarkt angewiesen ist und nicht noch hinterm Haus den Salat hat, den man pflücken kann. Das sind Probleme, die man hier wieder gar nicht kennt, auf die ich dann eben vor allem auf diesen UN-Reisen in Afrika stoße. Und darüber diskutiert man dann. Also es ist sehr grundlegend oft. Und zu guter Letzt ist natürlich es sehr wichtig, sich immer vor Ort umzugucken und nicht einfach irgendwie europäische Ideen da aufzupflanzen. Das ist oft genug gescheitert. So ein Kulturimperialismus, wo dann, da gibt es hervorragende Beispiele auch von so Newtowns, so Städten in Indien, die komplett von deutschen Planern in den 70ern geplant wurden. Und da ist dann auch wieder natürlich der Reis gepflanzt, auf dem zentralen Platz oder was auch immer. Das ist auch sehr interessant, da hat mein Kollege Alisa ein paar sehr interessante Untersuchungen gemacht und auch Fotos und so. Und natürlich ist da eine gute Lösung immer, dass man sich ein lokales Büro zum Partner nimmt, also dass man als ausländischer Stadtplaner einen lokalen Stadtplaner findet und dass man versucht, die Projekte gemeinsam zu bearbeiten. Der kennt dann dort die richtigen Leute, mit denen man reden muss, kennt sich aus, wie das Planungssystem, die Gesetze und so weiter funktionieren. Und man selber kann dann eher so das Know-how, was man hier hat, mit einbringen und eben frische Ideen bringen. Und das hat einen ganz positiven Nebeneffekt, dass gerade wenn man in Entwicklungsländern arbeitet, ja nicht nur darum geht, denen jetzt da eine tolle Stadt irgendwie hinzusetzen und dann wieder zu gehen, sondern es geht auch darum, so ein bisschen Transfer zu leisten. Also dieser alte Spruch, give a man a fish and he'll eat for a day, teach a man to fish and he'll eat forever. Dass man eben dann auch idealerweise den lokalen Stadtplanern etwas beigebracht hat und dass die das nächste Projekt dann auch irgendwie mit vielleicht etwas fortgeschritten nach einem besseren Prinzipien selber machen können. Das ist jetzt gerade nicht sehr marktwirtschaftlich gedacht für mich als privates Büro. Das ist jetzt auch gerade ein bisschen mein UN-Hut, den ich hier aufhabe. Aber dass man da halt auch Beispiele gibt. Na gut, ich meine, wenn ich das verstehe, ist ja Stadtplanung vor allem auch viel empirisches Wissen und viel Geschichtsblick. Man muss vor allem die Erfahrungen summieren, die da gesammelt wurden und sehen, ok, eure Stadt befindet sich jetzt an dem Punkt, was kann ich sozusagen aus der Geschichte lernen, wo es mal Städte gab, wenn auch zu einer ganz anderen Zeit, die aber in irgendeiner Form mit vergleichbaren Problemen zu kämpfen hatten, ja, Mangel an Kanalisation, etc., Infrastruktur-Schwierigkeiten. Ich denke, das fließt da ohnehin mit ein. Das lebenslange Lernen an der Stelle ist fast noch wichtiger als in anderen Bereichen. Ein großes Ding auch bei uns, also wenn man jetzt vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen mehr den Blick wieder mehr so hier auf unsere Region und die Probleme vor Ort lenken, ist ja der Klimawandel auf der einen Seite, aber eben vor allem diese ganze Nachhaltigkeit, die Änderung des Energie-Verbrauchs, Gebrauchs. Da steht uns ja im Prinzip auch ein langfristiger Wandel, nicht nur bevor, sondern findet teilweise auch schon statt. Wie groß ist das Thema so wirklich? Noch nicht groß genug? Nein, das Thema ist riesig mit allen Problemen, die das mit sich bringt, weil das nämlich so heiß und hip ist, dass das Schlagwort Nachhaltigkeit und Sustainability eigentlich fast sämtliche Bedeutung verloren hat, weil es einfach immer überall steht. Alles ist nachhaltig und muss nachhaltig sein. Es steht überall drauf und es gibt sogar... Genau. Wenn ich es so alle dekade. Es wird einfach überall drauf geklebt und das kann man auch an den Architekturen der letzten Jahre sehr gut sehen, dass einfach bei jedem Haus in jeglichem Kontext dann doch irgendwie noch ein grünes Dach oder ein Sonarpanel oder Windmühle noch mit da angebracht ist und in die Fassade integriert, weil das ist dann grün und nachhaltig und oft auch bar jeglichen gesunden Menschenverstandes. Aber grün. Aber grün. Und da muss mehr drüber nachgedacht werden. Und das ist auch eins meiner Hauptthemen. Vor allem um eben Nachhaltigkeit. Ich werde das Wort jetzt auch noch ein paar Mal verwenden, keine Sorge. Gut, dann ist dieser Podcast auch passbar vom Kleint. Richtig. Jetzt können wir das auch abhaken. Dass Nachhaltigkeit eben gedacht wird, nicht nur auf der Ebene des Hauses, was wirklich schon sehr stark, ein sehr stark bearbeitetes Feld ist und auch nicht nur technologisch, weil sehr viele Lösungen, gerade in Deutschland natürlich, einfach versuchen, das mit Technologische Innovation zu lösen. Und letztlich Nachhaltigkeit nicht nur ökologisch zu verstehen, sondern eben auch sozial, das heißt gesamtgesellschaftlich, und auch ökonomisch. Also es muss auch sozusagen weiterhin sich lohnen, Geld verdient werden, wenn man jetzt nicht ganz groß den Blick öffnet und in diese Wachstumsdebatte einsteigt, braucht überhaupt noch Wachstum und so weiter. Um mal ins Detail zu gehen, Nachhaltigkeit bedeutet im Moment eben vor allem, technische Lösungen zu finden, wie kann man das Auto bauen, das weniger verbraucht, wie kann man das Haus bauen, das wird ja auch in den Gesetzen insbesondere bei uns ganz klar verlangt, das Haus bauen, das einen bestimmten Dämmwert hat, das bestimmte Energiekoeffizienten erfüllt und so weiter. Und das funktioniert auch echt gut. Interessant wird das, wenn man das Ganze auf dem Maßstab der Stadt denkt. Dann plötzlich kann man sich nämlich die Frage stellen, gut, wir haben jetzt das perfekt gedämmte Einfamilienhaus und das Auto, das recht wenig verbraucht. Aber brauchen wir überhaupt das Einfamilienhaus und brauchen wir überhaupt das Auto? Plötzlich, wenn man in dem Maßstab geht, kann man viel radikalere Fragen stellen und sagen, können wir nicht ein Wohnmodell propagieren, was noch viel dichter ist, wo man sozusagen alles zu Fuß erreicht? Kann man nicht Systeme entwickeln, wo man überhaupt gar nicht mehr zur Arbeit fahren muss? Ich meine, das ist auch kein neues Thema mit dem Homeoffice und so weiter. Aber dass man eben versucht, nicht die Fragen einzeln zu beantworten, die sie stellen, sondern wiederum das als Gesamtsystem zu begreifen und das dann eben auch so zu denken. Und zum Beispiel ein Großteil des Energiewandels, in dem wir uns befinden, wird ganz klar nicht technisch gelöst werden, sondern da geht es vor allem um Verhaltensänderungen. Also es ist viel wichtiger, dass wir zum Beispiel die Leute daran gewöhnen, dass das Auto kein Statussymbol ist, als jetzt eine noch effizientere Dämmung zu erfinden oder den Benzinverbrauch nochmal ein paar Prozent runterzuschrauben. Also dadurch kann man sicher 40-50% des Gesamteffekts erreichen, einfach nur durch Verhaltensänderungen, wo wir auch schon recht weit sind mit Lichtausschalten und so weiter. Da ist übrigens auch, um wieder in einen anderen Erdteil zu springen, Kuba, ein hervorragendes Beispiel. Weil Kuba ist mir ins Auge gestochen, weil es gibt immer wieder diese Indizes, nicht nur zur Lebensqualität, sondern auch zu Lebens-, ja da gibt es zum Beispiel einen sehr wichtigen Vereinten Nationen-Index, das ist der HDI, der Human Development Index, also der Index der menschlichen Entwicklung, HDI. Und gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich Listen, Länder-Rankings, sortiert nach Bruttosozialprodukt, GDP. Und Kuba ist mir vor ein paar Jahren ins Auge gestochen, weil es das einzige Land ist, das im oberen Drittel rangierte auf dem Development Index, der solche Indikatoren hat, wie Kindersterblichkeit, Leser, wie heißt das, Literacy Rate, also wie viele Leute lesen und schreiben können, wie alt die Leute werden und so weiter. Und üblicherweise sind die Top 10 Länder in der Human Development Index-Liste natürlich auch die zehn reichsten Länder. Und der eine große Ausreißer von ein paar Jahren jedenfalls war Kuba, recht weit oben in dem einen Index und ganz ganz unten in dem anderen Index, wenn es um das Einkommen geht. Das heißt, wir haben da eigentlich schon vor unserer Nase natürlich kein freiwilliges Modell, aber ein Modell, wie Nachhaltigkeit funktionieren kann, gesamtgesellschaftlich. Und deswegen ist es sehr interessant, sich Kuba genauer anzugucken. Und da werden zum Beispiel im Kindergarten schon Lieder gesungen, wo es nicht irgendwie darum geht, was weiß ich, um irgendeine nette Story, sondern wenn ich aus dem Zimmer gehe, dann schalte ich immer das Licht aus. Sie haben einfach nicht genügend Elektrizitätswerke, um ansonsten die Bevölkerung zu versorgen. Das heißt, es wird ganz früh angefangen, sozusagen solche Verhaltensweisen anzutrainieren. Wenn du möchtest, ist das eine Art Brainwash, aber in dem Fall auf jeden Fall ein positiver. Naja, ich meine, ich kann das gut nachvollziehen. Ich war ja mal in Kuba und wenn einem irgendwas sofort auffällt, dann ist es halt, ich meine gerade weil es ein Land ist, was ja auch eben, also nicht nur durch das Verhalten der USA, aber auch sozusagen da in generellen ökonomischen Schwierigkeiten ist und natürlich nicht gerade in Ressourcenüberfluss schwimmt, aber trotzdem Prioritäten setzt. Das ist so ein Vermächtnis von Castro auf jeden Fall und gerade alle können lesen. Medizinische Versorgung hat eine hohe Bedeutung dort wie nirgendswo anders. Ja, als hier in New Orleans irgendwie die Überflutung war, da war es Cuba, die irgendwie den USA hier, wir haben ganz viele Ärzte, wollte nicht ein paar haben und so weiter, haben sie natürlich nicht angenommen, wie auch. Und es gibt dort, also zumindest habe ich keine Wahrnehmung, ich habe jetzt auch nicht alles gesehen, aber das ist auch so mein Kindesstand, sowas wie Slums gibt es da nicht. Also das ist sozusagen da ein Konzept, was es nicht gibt und das ist man ja, sagen wir mal, aus Lateinamerikanischen Gegenden nicht unbedingt gewohnt. Also muss da offensichtlich auch einiges richtig laufen, auch wenn man mit dem politischen Modell und dem gesellschaftlichen Druck, der dort ausgeübt wird, nicht unbedingt übereinstimmen muss. Und das ist eben das Wichtige, dass es gesamtgesellschaftlich gedacht ist und dass es eben auch nicht nur um Ökologie geht, sondern eben auch um diese soziale und ökonomische Nachhaltigkeit, dass Geschäftsmodelle entwickelt werden, die für alle funktionieren und dass halt nicht einer dieser Punkte für sich isoliert gesehen wird. Also wir können nicht nur wirtschaftlich denken, dann bleibt die Ökologie auf der Strecke und wir können nicht nur in grün denken und Arbeitslosigkeit erzeugen, weil plötzlich alle Produktionsstätten dicht machen müssen, weil sie die Norm nicht erfüllen und so weiter. Also da braucht es eine holistische Perspektive, einen holistischen Ansatz. Da braucht es einen holistischen Ansatz und das auch wieder auf den verschiedenen Maßstäben. Und das ist wichtig. Dann zu Klimawandel, was du gesagt hast, das ist ein riesiges Thema auch, vor allem, wenn man die NGOs betrachtet, weil es da einfach viele Gelder gibt und viel Forschung und Wissen gerade reingeht. Und das natürlich wichtig ist. Ein Großteil der menschlichen Ansiedlungen befinden sich am Meer, an den Küsten. Natürlich Handelsrouten, Zugang, Fischerei und so weiter. Und das heißt, dass auch ein Großteil der Menschen auch von dem Anstieg der Meeresspiegel, wie er erwartet, betroffen sein werden. Und da geht es jetzt natürlich auch wieder darum, was für Modelle man finden kann, um damit umzugehen. Die Leinen stellen sich das oft etwas falsch vor. Es ist jetzt nicht wie in irgendwelchen Katastrophenfilmen, dass plötzlich der Meeresspiegel zehn Meter höher sein wird. Die Bilder kennen man ja, dann ist es plötzlich so ganz Manhattan unter Wasser, so immer. Und alle fahren mit Booten rum. So wie in Venedig, wo es sich langsam einzieht. Manchmal schwappt es dann halt über und das ist halt früher nicht passiert. Also es gibt dann alle 100 Jahre, gibt es dann halt mal so eine Welle und die ist jetzt halt ein bisschen höher, als sie so vor 100 Jahren gewesen wäre. Und darum geht es. Oder selbst wenn die Meeresspiegel dann mal ein paar Zentimeter ansteigen, werden schon mal einige Städte betroffen sein, aber dann schwappt es halt eher so rein oder plötzlich ist das Grundwasser salzig statt süß. Das sind eher die Probleme. Es geht da um Sturmfluten und es geht um so langfristige klimatische, ganz langsame Veränderungen. Und ja, da müssen sich die Städte darauf vorbereiten. Und das passiert auf verschiedenste Art und Weise. Das passiert in Städten wie in New York, denkst du jetzt auch über so eine Wasserschleuse nach, wie wir sie in London und in Rotterdam haben. Dann gibt es an der Thamso oder an der Mars eine Riesenklappe, die zugeht. Ganz einfach. Das lohnt sich, wenn man mal in Rotterdamer sich das anzugucken, sich plötzlich sehr klein vorkommt, weil eine absurde Konstruktion da ist, wie eine Schere, die den ganzen Fluss zumacht, falls die Welle kommt. Der ganze Fluss? Der ganze Fluss wird zugemacht, genau. Und dann kann die Welle kommen, die prallt dann da ab. Wo steht das direkt am... Wenn man Google Earth mal ranzoomt, dann sieht man das auf halbem Weg zwischen Küste und Rotterdam Stadt. Und das heißt auf Holländisch, der Afsluitdijk ist was anderes. Das ist die... Ich weiß es nicht. Man erkennt es auf jeden Fall, eine große Struktur. Und genau im Osten von London gibt es auch die Thames Barrier auf Englisch. Die eh nicht funktionieren, nicht ganz so imposant ist. Und das ist halt eine Methode. Und natürlich ist es eine andere Methode. Ich war gerade auf den Philippinen für die UN, die sehr betroffen sind, weil es ja ein Inselstaat ist. Und natürlich auch die einzelnen Inseln, sozusagen einzelne kleine Berge, die aus dem Meer ragen sind. Das heißt, es ist nun ein ganz dünner Küstenstreifen besiedelt. Danach wird es sofort höher und man kann da nicht wohnen. Und da werden dann einfach die ganzen Ansiedlungen verlegt werden und gehen weiter ins Landesinnere. Also da muss jetzt auch so ein Wandel geben, dass halt neue Städte, Ansiedlungen gebaut werden, dass halt bei der nächsten Flut einfach weniger Leute umkommen. Die Herausforderungen sind dann je nach Region anders. Die Türkei hat ja gerade, das ist wieder ein bisschen näher bei uns, ein Riesenproblem mit den Erdbeben. Die haben ein Erbe von informell, also von selbstgewachsener Stadt, von informell ohne jegliche Baunorm gebaute Häuser, in denen Millionen leben. Istanbul ist mit Moskau im Moment die größte europäische Stadt, mit auch so geschätzten 15 bis 18 Millionen Menschen, von denen ein Großteil in Häusern wohnen, die bei einem stärkeren Beben einfach einstürzen. Das heißt, da ist die Regierung auch dabei, gerade ein Riesenprogramm aufzulegen, das eben erdbebensicher gebaut wird. Künftig? Künftig, Häuser umgebaut werden, Leute umgesiedelt werden, so schnell, dass es daneben geht. Ich freu mich die ganze Zeit, wenn man da so viel Wissen kombinieren muss und wenn man so viel auch auf Erfahrungen setzt, mit was für Werkzeugen ihr da eigentlich voranschreitet. Was es da eigentlich so für Hilfsmittel gibt, um all dieses ganze Wissen auch zusammenzutragen. Und letztendlich das auch zu einer Anwendung zu bringen. Gerade im Hinblick auch, dass wenn man jetzt sagt, da kommt man hin, da muss man überhaupt das ganze Wissen fallen lassen. Also wie man dann sozusagen auch das Neuhinzuge, diese Entscheidung selbst belegt und dann auch quasi dann weiter recherchierbar macht. Ja, also es gibt vielleicht zwei verschiedene Antworten auf die Frage. Zum einen gibt es diese Kernarbeit des Stadtplaners. Das ist jetzt wirklich der Entwurf, wie man das so macht, mit was für Tools man da arbeitet. Und dann letztlich, wie du die Frage formuliert hast, etwas weitergefasst. Wie sieht denn so meine tägliche Arbeit aus? Was benutze ich denn da? Und das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel anders wie bei dir. Also ich e-mail und schreibe eigentlich die meiste Zeit im Moment, weil es eben um Kommunikation geht und um Verteilen von Wissen und um Organisieren und um Diskutieren. Da kann es genauso natürlich um Akquirieren von Projekten geht, um Steuern von laufenden Projekten, wo man mit den einzelnen Mitspielern diskutiert oder eben auch in dieser Rolle als Berater. Ja, ich bin sehr für die UN, was eigentlich nur Reden ist. Ich mache da sehr wenig selber die Arbeit. Ich kommentiere zu der Arbeit anderer. Als Kritiker. Als Kritiker, ja genau. Und eben als Berater sozusagen, was hier von der Bezeichnung drin steckt. Wenn man jetzt die Arbeit, die eigentliche planerische Entwurfsarbeit sich anguckt, dann kommt es einfach darauf an, wie modern man es sein möchte. Das Grundwerkzeug ist auf jeden Fall die Rolle Transparentpapier und der Stift unternehmen Taschenrechner. So sieht es aus. Das heißt, man druckt sich einen Plan aus. Wenn es keinen Plan gibt, dann haben wir jetzt Google Earth. Und druckt sich das groß aus. Und dann nimmt man einen bunten, am besten nicht zu dünnen Stift, damit man sich nicht in Details verliert, und zeigt es dann so drüber und versucht es erst mal zu verstehen. Und das ist bis heute, egal was für fortgeschrittene Werkzeuge wir haben, eins der grundlegendsten und wichtigsten Werkzeuge, um überhaupt zu verstehen, was los ist. Das versuche ich auch jetzt in meiner Lehre, den Studenten immer wieder beizubringen, weil viele so eine gewisse Scheu haben, jetzt wirklich noch den Stift in die Hand zu nehmen. Man sieht ja alles am Bildschirm und so. Das Problem ist nämlich folgendes, die Situation ist immer so komplex, dass man sie in der Gesamtheit nicht verstehen kann. Letztlich muss man aber gesamtheitlich denken. Und es geht nicht anders, als das Problem natürlich in seine einzelnen Bestandteile zu zerlegen, um die dann hoffentlich hinterher irgendwie wieder zusammenführen zu können. Und das ist oft so, um jetzt die räumliche Situation der Stadt zu verstehen, dass es sich absolut lohnt, einfach mal alle Wasserflächen da durchzuzeichnen, fast so mal nach Zahlen. Durch dieses Transparentpapier zeichnet man das durch, dann hat man einen Plan nur mit dem Wasser. Dann nimmt man das nächste Transparentpapier und zeichnet mal alle Wohngebiete ein oder überhaupt alles, was bebaut ist. Und dann macht man eins nur mit dem Straßennetz. Dann vielleicht, wenn man die Informationen hat, guckt man mal, wo die Industrie und wo die Geschäfte und wo wohnen ist, dann nimmt man drei verschiedene Farben oder so. Und am Ende hat man eine Vielzahl von Einzelplänen und versteht eben viel besser, was diese einzelnen Ebenen, diese einzelnen Layer bedeuten und wie die miteinander interagieren. Wo ist was, wo ist etwas konzentriert? Das ist ja komisch. An der Küste gibt es gar kein Wohnen. Okay, vielleicht gibt es da Überflutung oder alle wohnen an der Küste. Klar, wegen des Blicks oder man versteht plötzlich, was los ist in der Stadt, was so die Treibe sind. Natürlich unterhält man sich auch mit den Leuten. Und dann, wenn man wirklich diese Analyse gemacht hat, dann fängt man an zu entwerfen und man kann dann natürlich, das ist vielleicht so das klassische Bild, was natürlich nicht mehr funktioniert. Man kann dann natürlich in seinem Büro sitzen und dann die großartige Idee haben, basierend auf der Analyse, jetzt die Stadt oder die Erweiterung zu zeichnen. Aber natürlich geht es heutzutage vielmehr darum, eine Strategie zu entwickeln und mit den einzelnen Spielern, sagen wir der Stadtverwaltung, den Firmen, die in der Stadt sitzen. Wer sonst noch was zu sagen hat, die wichtigen Player eben, zu sehen, wie es weitergeht. Da braucht es ein wirtschaftliches Konzept und so weiter. Und auch da idealerweise zeichnet man da verschiedene Szenarios, trifft sich mit den Verantwortlichen, diskutiert die, diskutiert in welche Richtung es gehen soll, welche Szenarios funktionieren, zum Beispiel welche Dichte, welche Funktionen, wie hoch möchte man bauen und so weiter. Und um zurück zu den Werkzeugen zu kommen, das kann man natürlich auf verschiedenen technologischen Niveaus machen. Man kann das machen mit einem Stift und einem Taschenrechner, was oft eben sehr schnell und ad hoc ist und sehr nützlich. Und das Ganze kann man dann auch ein bisschen fortgeschrittener machen, sagen wir mit Excel statt des Taschenrechners und mit einer CAD, also Computer Aided Design, einer Software statt des Stiftes, wo man eben am Bildschirm das Gleiche macht und präziser und replizierbarer. Und dann kann man diese technologische Komplexität noch weiter treiben. Es gibt sogenannte GIS-Systeme, ein Geo-Information Database, und die versuchen eben sozusagen die Excel, um es jetzt mal ganz locker zu sagen, die Excel-Tabelle mit dem Plan direkt zu kombinieren. Also du hast dann da eben einzelne Objekte, die wiederum dann schon Daten beinhalten können. Das ist dann eben nicht nur ein Rechteck, sondern plötzlich ist es ein Rechteck und du weißt, da leben 25 Menschen, so und so viel Prozent sind bebaut. Und das gehört dem und dem. Und letztlich gibt es dann sogar noch Tools, wo du sozusagen Szenarios entwickeln kannst, wo du bestimmte Parameter eingibst. Und dann daraus eben siehst, wie sich die Stadt weiterentwickelt. Das ist natürlich hochkomplex zu benutzen. Also du könntest zum Beispiel eingeben, was für ein Verkehrsaufkommen du hast, wo die Leute im Moment wohnen, was der Durchsatz der Straßen ist. Und dann gibst du noch das Bevölkerungswachstum mit rein und dann versuchst du zu projizieren, wie viele neue Straßen und wo sich dann so ergeben. Da wird dann dieses neue Stadtteil gleich hingerinnert. Na ja, es wird dann gleich hingerinnert. Natürlich mit Vorsicht zu genießen, weil dann veränderst du den Indikator um 0,3% und alles sieht komplett anders aus. Aber das ist so die Bleeding Edge. Darauf läuft es hinaus oder bleibt es dann doch eher beim Transparentpapier? Ja, ich bin ja ein bisschen Vertreter der Transparentpapier-Fraktion, wobei ich überhaupt nicht technologiescheu bin, ganz im Gegenteil. Ich sehe einfach nur so, das hatten wir am Anfang, dass die Stadt eins der komplexesten Systeme ist, das wir im Moment so haben als Menschen. Und das lässt sich eben kaum modellieren. Natürlich lassen sich Einzelaspekte modellieren, der Verkehr, das Abwasser, gerade die infrastrukturellen Bestandteile. Aber es spielen eben so viele andere Dinge rein. Kulturelle Aspekte, wo möchten die Menschen gerade hinziehen? Was boomt gerade? Und das kann echt unverherrbar sein. Plötzlich ist es Neukölln und nicht Friedrichshain und so weiter. Und bis da es eine Software modellieren kann, vergeht noch eine Weile. Und ich denke, am Ende wird das eine Kombination aus den einzelnen Tools sein. Immer wieder. Es ist auf jeden Fall in Ordnung, so eine Szenariosoftware laufen zu haben, um vielleicht die als Unterstützung des Prozesses zu verwenden. Aber wenn man schnell etwas verstehen will, wird es weit in der Stift bleiben. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch andere Werkzeuge, sagen wir, um mit Einbeziehung der Bevölkerung zu erzielen. Da kann man zum Beispiel sogar mit Lego spielen, wenn man mal nicht nur die Spezialisten am Tisch haben will, sondern auch die Anwohner, wenn es um einen Platz oder um ein kleineres Projekt geht. Aber ich könnte mir doch durchaus vorstellen, dass man häufig so den Bedarf verspürt, so, oh Mann, jetzt würde ich hier gerne mal eine qualifizierte Einschätzung machen, was jetzt hier der Plan richtig wäre, aber jetzt fehlt mir hier einfach eine Zahl, jetzt fehlt mir einfach eine Grundlage, eine Information und vielleicht eben gar nicht mal so eine einfach, geografisch wahrnehmbare, sondern eben statistische oder noch besser erfasste Basisdaten, was ist jetzt so selten oder kommt das eher häufiger vor? Was sind dann so die Sachen, wonach man sich sehnt? Wo muss da nachgeliefert werden? Mir fallen jetzt halt so Sachen an, so neuere Entwicklungen. Auf der einen Seite, naja, sowas wie Wikipedia, die jetzt mit diesem Wikidata-Projekt zum Beispiel auch versuchen in zunehmendem Maße die Dinge nicht nur irgendwie greifbar, sondern eben auch quantifizierbar zu machen. Oder Open-Street-Map, die ja auch wirklich einen Detailgrad bei Infrastrukturelementen ermöglichen, der so vorher nicht da war. Sind das... Ja, also wir leben sicherlich jetzt schon in einer glorreichen Zeit, weil zum einen muss man sagen, dass in dem Kontext der entwickelteren Länder die Daten oft in sehr hohem Detailgrad vorhanden sind. Und jetzt eigentlich gerade es eine Parallelentwicklung gibt, wo so populäre Werkzeuge, also Crowd-Source-Werkzeuge, den professionell erstellten Datenbanken sehr nahe kommen. Also es gab schon das komplett in Vektoren gezeichnete Berlin- Kataster-Plan. Sicherlich, ich weiß es nicht, vor ein, zwei Jahrzehnten gab es das schon. Aber plötzlich hat es Google auch. Ein komplett anderes Entstehungsprozess. Plötzlich muss ich es nicht mehr nur, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es im Fall von Berlin ist, für 20.000 Euro von der Stadtverwaltung kaufen. Plötzlich habe ich es einfach online. Und das ist natürlich vor allem in dem Kontext von weniger entwickelnd und hochinteressant. Google Earth, hast du einfach vielleicht eine etwas anderen Auflösung überall. Und das ist ein unglaublicher Sprung nach vorne. Für viele Gegner in Afrika, wo ich arbeite, wo es vor wenigen Jahren noch einfach gar nichts gab. Oder man musste halt ein Flugzeug bestellen, dass da man drüber fliegt und Fotos macht. Das war ein ganz anderer Aufwand. Auch um sozusagen vor Ort auch mal so Vergleiche zu ziehen. Hier guck mal da, ist es so und hier ist es so. Ganz genau. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, dass die Datenlage hier gut ist. Also was man sich wünscht, sind dann eben genau diese Layer, von denen ich eben gesprochen habe. Räumliche Indikatoren, wo ist Wasser, wo ist Land. Dann rechtliche Dinge, wem gehört es. Oder was liegt da unter der Erde. Oder dann eben auch soziale Faktoren, wie viel Arbeitslosigkeit gibt es in der Gegend. Wie alt sind die Leute, wie kinderreich sind die Familien, wenn es das eben gibt. Und je nachdem ist da natürlich die Lage, die Informationslage unterschiedlich, wo man ist. Ich glaube, in Zukunft wird es sehr interessant, dass man eine viel mehr real-time Informationslage hat, der Stadt. Letztlich tragen wir jetzt schon alle ihr persönliches Identifikations-Device mit sich in der Tasche rum. Und wenn man jetzt mal alle Privatheitsbedenken beiseite lässt, könnte man direkt sofort mappen, wo sich die Leute gerade wie schnell wohin bewegen, und zwar jetzt. Und klassisch sind die Stadtplanungsdimensionen zeitlich, indem man denkt ganz anders. Man hat oft den Plan von vor fünf Jahren und entwickelt ein Konzept, was über die nächsten 25 Jahre umgesetzt werden soll. Und natürlich wird sich das, denke ich, mit dem technologischen Fortschritt stark beschleunigen. Und das wird sehr interessant, dass man dann eben plötzlich, das gibt es ja auch in den Kinderschuhen schon so, ad hoc die Stadt verändert, ad hoc Straßensysteme, Verkehrssysteme verändert oder ad hoc Informationen sammelt, die akut sehr relevant sind. Vielleicht auch als Reaktion auf irgendwelche Katastrophen, wenn wir eben von Überflutung und so weiter gesprochen haben, dass man da eben einfach viel schneller und viel näher in der Stadt arbeiten kann. Ja, dass man aber auch vielleicht Dinge, auch bestimmte Sachen überhaupt erst versteht, die so bisher noch gar nicht sichtbar waren. Also gerade im Verkehrshinsicht aber eben auch so, wie werden Plätze genutzt? Wo die Trampelpfade sind, das sieht man, aber ich glaube, dass viele Bewegungen in dem Sinne noch gar nicht so ohne Weiteres sichtbar sind. Ja klar, du hast recht, was man sicherlich sagen kann, ist, dass die Stadtplanung prinzipiell damit zu kämpfen hat, dass sie keine präzise Wissenschaft ist. Also darauf zielt deine Frage ja so ein bisschen ab, was sind so die Indikatoren, die du dir wünscht? Möchte man da nicht mal wirklich eine konkrete Zahl haben? Und ich habe in meiner Laufbahn immer gedacht, irgendwann wirst du es wirklich verstehen, wie es funktioniert, aber inzwischen habe ich begriffen, dass es keiner weiß und alle nur ihren Finger befeuchten und versuchen zu verstehen, woher der Wind bläst. Und es geht sozusagen nur um das Ausmaß, wie gut du bist, wie richtig du rätst. Aber es gibt nie die richtige oder die einzige Lösung. Das ist eine Gefühlsache, wo die persönliche Abstraktion des Problems eine große Rolle spielt. An der Stelle verstehe ich auch den Hang zu Transparenzfolie. Durch die Reduktion wird man ja geradezu gezwungen, auch gleich richtig zu interpretieren. Und dann auch das eine oder andere Detail einfach mal beiseite zu lassen, weil es nur von der Lösung abbringt.
Ja, genau. Und das sind dann auch oft ganz einfache Indikatoren, die richtig sind. Zum Beispiel, das empfehle ich sehr, sich das mal anzugucken. Es gibt einen Film, der 1979 gedreht wurde von einem gewissen William White. White mit Y, nicht mit I. Der mal untersucht hat, wie sich in einem Fall von New York, wie sich die Leute im öffentlichen Raum verhalten. Also wo die laufen und sitzen auf Plätzen, weil du das gerade angesprochen hast, wenn man die Trampelpfade ja nicht sehen kann. Und vor allem, weil es so unglaublich viel schlechte Plätze gibt, überall auf der Welt. Also Plätze, wo man sich nicht wohlfühlt, wo die ohne Aufenthaltsqualität und so weiter. Und dann der Film ist äußerst unterhaltend, der heißt The Social Life of Small Urban Spaces. Soziale Leben, kleine öffentliche Räume. Und dass das gut ist, dass sie sehr wissenschaftlich vorgegangen sind. Also sie haben Kameras aufgestellt, gefilmt, so Timelapse-Movies gemacht, die Bewegung nachgezeichnet, analysiert. Und da merkt man wieder, dass es oft dann auch sehr einfach ist. Also es gibt dann so sehr charmant vorgebrachte Zusammenfassungen. Wie zum Beispiel, die Leute setzen sich dahin, wo es was zu sitzen gibt und wo die Sonne scheint. Und das ist total egal, ob das ein Betonklotz auf Sitzhöhe ist oder die total durchdesignte Holzbank. Und das ist total egal, ob das direkt an der Straße ist oder zurückgesetzt ist. Es wird plötzlich sehr einfach. Und es gibt, also ich will damit sagen, es gibt immer wieder Ansätze, dann doch wissenschaftlich zu sein in einem Teilbereich und das funktioniert auch. Und das ist dann immer sehr erfrischend. Und wiederum spricht es auch fast wieder für die Einfachheit der Mittel. Es ist eben kein, in diesem Fall jetzt kein hochkomplexes Modell der Bewegungsmuster notwendig, sondern das ist, am Ende kommt man doch wieder zu einer sehr menschlichen Dimension zurück. Es gibt eine andere interessante Beobachtung aus dem Film. Das hat auch mit etwas sehr Menschlichen zu tun, dass sie festgestellt haben, dass öffentliche Räume, in denen man das Sitzmöbel bewegen kann, viel beliebter sind. Oder anders gesagt, wenn sich Menschen hinsetzen, sagen wir im Café, aber auch auf einem Platz, wo die Stühle nicht komplett fest sind, dann haben sie eine Tendenz, den Stuhl immer noch mal 20 cm zu verschieben. Sich sozusagen die eigene Position zu schaffen, sich diesen Ort wirklich anzueignen und so möchte ich jetzt sitzen. Und wenn man solche Dinge versteht, kann man plötzlich mit sehr wenigen Mitteln wiederum sehr, sehr gute Sachen machen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum ich mich in Biergärten manchmal so unwohl fühle. Ich sehe gerade hier der Film, der ist auch im Internet.
Ja, empfehlenswert.
Ja, wird alles verlinkt hier in der umfangreichen Link-Dokumentation unseres epischen Podcasts, den wir jetzt glaube ich auch langsam mal ein bisschen zum Ende bringen müssen. Ich merke schon, dass das Thema genauso viel Tiefe und Dimension hat, wie ich vorher schon vermutet hatte. Ich weiß nicht, was man jetzt noch zum Abschluss unter Umständen erwähnen sollte. Hast du noch irgendwas auf dem Herzen gesehen, dass man noch tausend Sachen ansprechen könnte?
Ja, man könnte noch tausend Sachen ansprechen, wie du sagst. Ich finde auch, dass wir jetzt einen guten Überblick gegeben haben, was man noch sagen kann vielleicht ist, dass ich in meiner jüngeren Arbeit feststelle, dass ich immer wieder am Rande stehe zu sagen, eigentlich müsste es jetzt in die Politik gehen. Weil man eben so oft als Planer an die Grenzen gerät, was man räumlich machen kann, und es dann eben darum geht, gesellschaftliche Veränderungen hervorzurufen oder einfach neue Gesetze zu schaffen oder eine Bewusstseinsänderung. Oder dass es darum geht, dass man vielleicht mit unterschiedlichen Geldströmen agieren könnte. Also da merke ich manchmal, dass es da auch Grenzen gibt. Es gibt so eine Natur-Tendenz, nicht nur von Stadtplanern, sondern auch von Architekten zu ihren Bereich, das ist wahrscheinlich in vielen Bereichen so, als den zu sehen, der Anfang und Ende der Lösung ist. Aber natürlich ist die Stadtplanung ein wichtiger, vielleicht auch der integrierende Teil, der aber genauso wichtig ist wie Governance, also Gesetzgebung und Regierungsführung oder die ökonomischen Strukturen der Stadt oder eben die Infrastrukturentwicklung.
Ich meine, wenn man schon holistisch an das Thema Stadt rangehen will, wie wir es ja schon gesagt haben, dann gehört natürlich da die Politik dazu, weil nichts verändert dann die Stadt am Ende doch mehr als die Politik. Ein Programm, was von der Politik nicht aufgesetzt wird, das findet dann am Ende nicht statt und kann auch nicht wirklich geplant werden.
Richtig. Ich habe da ein Beispiel wieder aus Aleppo, wo es genau um das ging. Da ging es auch um die Straßen, die zu verstopft waren. Wir brauchen jetzt eine Lösung für unsere Straßen. Dann habe ich angefangen zu erzählen, wir könnten hier eine neue Straße bauen. Aber ich habe auch gesehen, dass ein paar Kinder jetzt hier in dem Bezirk, wo ich gerade wohne, mit dem Fahrrad fahren. Es gibt sonst keine Fahrradfahrer in Aleppo. Das wäre doch ganz gut, wenn mehr Leute Fahrrad fahren würden. Damit macht dann natürlich sofort eine gesellschaftliche Pandora-Büchse auf. Weil man dann nämlich irgendwie sagt, dann haben sie gefragt, ja, Fahrrad ist ja gut. Wie könnte man das dann erreichen? Wichtig wäre es natürlich, dass wichtige Figuren des öffentlichen Lebens als gut ein Beispiel vorangehen. Wie wäre es denn zum Beispiel, Herr Bürgermeister, wenn Sie mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit fahren würden? Und das ist natürlich skandalös, weil das Auto ist das Statussymbol. Und das geht schon nicht, dass das Auto nicht schwarz oder kleines ist. Es muss die schwarze Limousine sein. Oder sagen wir, man will mehr ein wirtschaftlich effizienteres Leben oder man will eine höhere Integration der einzelnen Bevölkerungsteile erreichen. Gut, die Frauen können nicht zur Arbeit fahren, weil sie kein eigenes Auto besitzen. Die Frau auf dem Fahrrad, das geht ja schon mal gar nicht. Das heißt, man kommt ganz schnell in einen Bereich, wo man sagt, da muss man dann in den Schulen anfangen.
Beziehungsweise stößt man auch an kulturelle Grenzen.
Oder man würde sagen, man macht das Autofahren durch Steuern so teuer, dass die Leute einfach gezwungen sind, sich andere Lösungen zu suchen. Da muss man auch als Stadtpartner sagen, das kann man vielleicht auch anders machen. Nicht nur durch bauen und räumliche Lösungen.
Ich versuche es mir die ganze Zeit zu verkneifen, aber jetzt, wo du selber noch mal auf Aleppo gekommen bist, möchte ich das zum Abschluss fragen. Du hast ja viel Zeit verbracht. Aleppo, wir wissen es alle, ist zu dem aktuellen Zeitpunkt. Und den kann man vielleicht auch kurz nennen. Ich werde immer dafür kritisiert, dass ich das Datum nie sage. Wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie Januar 2013, der Bürgerkrieg in Syrien ist voll im Gange, auch in Aleppo, eine der ersten Städte der Welt überhaupt, wo du gewesen bist. Also ich bin jetzt nicht so hier auf eine emotionale Ebene, wie man sich jetzt fühlt, wenn man mal da war. Das ist wahrscheinlich sowieso schon schlimm genug. Aber es ist ja auch eine Stadt, die jetzt insofern, dadurch, dass sie so alt ist, auch ganz gut zeigt, was so funktioniert hat über lange Zeit und was davon auch noch übrig bleibt. Was hast du da mitgenommen aus dieser Region?
Ohje, eine Riesenfrage. Um bei dem Geschichtlichen anzufangen, erstmal ist es genau eine von diesen zehn Städten, die sich darum streitet, die älteste Stadt der Welt zu sein, in der heute noch Menschen leben. Also es ist auch ganz interessant, wenn man durch die Stadt läuft und man sieht einen römischen Überrest irgendwo. Ja, die waren ja gerade erst da, die Römer. Neulich, genau. Das ist so ein bisschen anders dort. Und das ist eigentlich eine faszinierende Stadt für mich gewesen, aus dem Grund, weil es ganz unerwartet ein Beispiel war für ein, das hört sich jetzt fast zynisch an, aber für ein friedliches Zusammenleben von höchst unterschiedlichen religiösen, kulturellen und ethnischen Gruppen.
Das hast du ja schon angesprochen, ja.
Da gab es einfach alles in einem viel höheren Ausmaß und in einer viel höheren Durchmischung, als wir es hier in Deutschland überhaupt kennen. Da gab es die Christen und die Soniten und die Schiiten. Und dann kamen sie noch aus verschiedenen Gegnern. Da gab es die armenischen Flüchtlinge, die in Zeiten des türkischen Genozids eben nach Syrien geflüchtet sind. Da gibt es die Arameer, da gibt es die Araber. Und alle haben irgendwie dieses Netzwerk gebildet und coexistiert. In einer Stadt, die ganz klar ihre besten Zeiten gesehen hat. Das war auch ein ganz klar vorherrschendes Gefühl. In dem Alpina von heute, der wusste irgendwie, früher war es besser und die waren weiter vorne. Was auch immer das zu bedeuten hat. Und jetzt läuft es irgendwie nicht so gut und wir sind nicht mehr so vernetzt. Das hat alle möglichen Gründe. Die Seidenstraße ist durch Aleppo gelaufen. Da hat das ganz anders geboomt als heute. Und jetzt in den letzten Jahren gab es sogar der einzige Handelspartner, wo Aleppo noch die Durchgangsstadt war. Und Irak im Osten ist sozusagen weggefallen durch die zwei Kriege. Und Aleppo war ziemlich isoliert und hat so ein bisschen in der Erinnerung gespägt und war schon noch der Handelsknotenpunkt von Syrien, aber eben nicht mehr für die Region und schon gar nicht global. Ich bin da doch immer wieder auf eine komplette Fehleinschätzung im Selbstverständnis gestoßen, die es nicht wahrhaben wollen, dass die guten Zeiten vorbei sind. Also ich habe dann auch im Gespräch mit der Stadtverwaltung immer gefragt, was zeichnet Aleppo aus? Aleppo ist die wichtigste Handelsstaat im Mittleren Osten. Istanbul? Dubai? Verstehst du, da gab es noch so ein anderes Selbstverständnis. Und auch einen großartigen und auch positiven Stolz. Weil der sich eben auf Jahrtausende von Kultur gestützt hat und sagt, okay, jetzt ist es zwar nicht so gut, aber eigentlich sind wir trotzdem recht wichtig. Und das sehen wir jetzt gelassen, diese kurze Periode, wo es gerade nicht so läuft. Und dann, das hat viel damit zu tun, hat mich auch noch sehr beeindruckt, wie gut die informellen Systeme funktionieren, wenn man sich nicht auf die formellen Systeme verlassen kann. Das kennt man ja als Deutscher. Wenn man sich irgendwie beschwert, dann ruft man halt die Polizei an oder geht halt ins Rathaus zum Bürgercenter oder so was, wenn man irgendwas will. Das konnte man in aller Epo komplett vergessen. Aber man kannte irgendjemanden, der das Problem gelöst hat. Und da gibt es auch gravierende kulturelle Unterschiede. Da passiert dann viel, was man selber ganz schnell als Fett anwirtschaft, oder gar Korruption bezeichnen würde. Was aber gar nicht so gemeint ist. Weil es kulturell schon immer so funktioniert hat und anders gar nicht geht. Es wäre zum Beispiel dann absurd, darauf zu warten, dass die Stadt das offiziell genehmigt. Man hat doch schon den Freund gefragt, der jemand bei der Stadt kennt. Damit ist das Thema erledigt. Wo man selber denkt, das ist doch nicht okay. Aber anders geht das nicht und das funktioniert. Und da gibt es natürlich kein besseres Modell. Aber ich habe dort auch wiederum gemerkt, was man vielleicht in Deutschland hier vermisst. Gerade eben dieses soziale Netzwerk, dass die Nachbarn sich kennen und alle füreinander da ist. Weil man sich eben nicht auf die Polizei, Feuerwehr, Altersversorgung, Rente oder was auch immer verlassen kann. Sondern da fällt einfach keiner durch Netzwerk, man sich kennt und sich gegenseitig hilft. Das ist auf jeden Fall ganz anders. Natürlich geht das einher mit unglaublicher Einschränkung der persönlichen Freiheit. Ich kann hier in Berlin machen, was ich will, ohne dass es meine Nachbarn mitkriegen. Ist denen egal. Und in Syrien wissen die Nachbarn alle, dass dich gerade jemand besucht hat am Wochenende. Dieses Mädchen. Und wir waren anders. Aber auf der anderen Seite...
Wenn du hier fällst, fällst du auch tief.
Hier kannst du zwei Wochen in der Wohnung liegen, tot. Und die Nachbarn wundern sich nicht, dass es müffelt. Und dort ist nach einer Stunde irgendjemand da, wenn, was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, auf dem Herd noch was steht und es riecht angebrannt. Und fragt das alles in Ordnung. Das ist halt einfach anders. Und ja, das sind so die Unterschiede. Das war eine sehr wichtige Phase in meinem Leben natürlich, das mal zu sehen.
Tja, eigentlich würde ich jetzt jedem mal empfehlen, da mal hinzufahren, aber es ist nun gerade nicht so klar, wie es mit der Stadt weitergeht und gerade, wie das soziale Gefüge diese Zeit jetzt überstehen wird. Müssen wir leider offen lassen. Aber alles andere haben wir ja zumindest schon mal angesprochen.
Ich danke dir für die Einladung.
Ja, das war sehr angemessen hier. Nicht nur, weil es die 200. ist, sondern weil ich das Thema auch selber spannend genug finde. Und die Nähe zum Leben ist ja hier auch gut deutlich geworden. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, jetzt haben wir ja auch schon die 3-Stunden-Marke wieder gerissen. Das war normal.
Das war meine Ambition.
Zum Ende kommen, die 3-Stunden-Marke reißen. Ja, haben wir geschafft. Okay, ich sage vielen Dank, Thomas. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war es, CRE, die 200.